kamala harris
says she's not going to go to the border
because it would just be a
gesture but she actually went to
guatemala where she was greeted by
protesters who were saying they liked
trump better go home and that they said
trump won and uh then kamala harris said
something really interesting she said
don't come to the border
i was actually surprised that she said
that considering but
not really i mean joe biden said
something similar there's a big
difference between what they say and
what they do
and so far their policies have been
pretty bad
they finally formally ended the
remaining mexico policy trump came out
said a whole bunch of criticizing them
and uh i i gotta say beyond this monday
it's crazy there's a lot of news we got
an op-ed on the wall street journal
saying the science
suggests a lab leak we got the scientist
who told fauci a in january of last year
that there may have it may have been
engineered deleting his entire twitter
account
as to after people pointed out that what
he was sending to fauci
and what he was tweeting were completely
different which is
very weird suggesting the scientists
doing the research the entire time were
acting politically
saying one thing behind closed doors but
then saying certain things publicly for
some reason i i wonder why
what's important and we got some yeah it
is we got other news too there's a
this is crazy uh on amazon driver
brutally beat a woman
after she refused to check her white
privilege and complained about a package
delivery
you wonder where that racist psychotic
behavior comes from
sorry man look i think racism is bad i
think anybody getting attacked you know
based on race is extremely horrifying
and there's a problem when the left is
exacerbating racial
hatred and violence and uh we're going
to talk about that so we're we're
hanging out once again with
sheamus of freedom tunes great to be
here great to be here and i just wanted
to comment on the story about that
scientist not being completely
forthcoming about the information he had
it's interesting because i was told that
we should trust the scientists but as it
turns out they're human beings who
sometimes say things that aren't true
man it's like almost all of them are
lying there's there's right now there's
a weird investigation
i should say there's an investigation
and it's weird because it's like this
guy says to fouchy privately hey it
looks engineered then publicly he's like
nah it's crazy it's a conspiracy
theory but then like a few months later
fauci gives apparently one of his
organizations a grant i
it's still being looked into so i don't
want to make you know we don't we don't
have everything pulled up but
i'm doing a lot of research on this the
journalism of trying to figure out what
actually happened there
but some people are suggesting maybe he
said the right thing
publicly it's good for fouchy and then
an organization or maybe it's just
coincidence we don't we don't know so
we'll look into this there's a lot of
there's a lot of rumors flying around
and we got ian's children crosstalk in
the house
you know there's no one i'd rather talk
about uh racial violence with the new
sheamus
thank you i appreciate that ian i don't
know what that means but i will always
take it as a compliment
that's a weird compliment i don't know
what it means but ian's saying it i know
ian has a good heart
it's because there's no one who
understands racism better
than a white catholic irish guy that's
true that's actually completely true
your ancestors have been through it i
mean
irish people weren't actually actually
in the early days that's actually a good
question
couldn't drink from the white drinking
fountains that's actually that's true i
mean yeah yeah dude i've got stories
also from
family members that i i mentioned this
on a show before i don't want to divulge
too much and give up too much of my
family history but yeah irish people
didn't have it super great when they
first came to the united states
yeah it's so weird yeah yeah i'm in the
corner as well
similarly irish to sheamus but i think
my family came later
but uh when did your family come to the
states i would just say in like uh the
20s they moved to new mexico
okay yeah okay mine was like the early
1900s yeah
probably probably just between your yeah
just before yours ian looks like some
kind of nordic
what
[Laughter]
irish and german and i think maybe
neanderthal
possibly that explains it that's the big
forehead
yeah not the eyebrows you know what i
mean i'm irish and british so i'm
internally conflicted and fighting oh
i'm sorry
yeah i don't know why you just wouldn't
get into the irish yeah
what's the conflict there what does
england even have against ireland
i know or vice versa they just choose
the irish
they they both love each other there's
nothing nothing bad between all these
countries have you been to ireland
yes well i've been in northern ireland
what were you doing over there there was
a uh
a big the it's the bonfire night it's i
forgot what it's called uh i was in
belfast and they lit they stack up like
60 foot wood like so they stack up all
of these wooden pallets super high
and torch it and the fire is so intense
that
it like burns holes in the ground whoa
it's yeah i guess the left says it's
like a bunch of fascists or something
and i'm like i don't know man what do
they not say that about though
i know i know so but it's like it's it's
northern ireland
so you know the one group and the other
group and i'm like i don't know man like
i'm just here i'm like a tourist we're
walking around and people are starting
fires and i'm just chilling was it like
a festival
it's like they do it every year oh i
guess it's like it's like bonfire nights
like a big thing
great country although i've only been at
the airport in dublin yeah i've never
been once
i haven't actually been to uh you know
ireland i was in northern ireland so
there's like you know
yeah exactly but it'll be interesting
between the irish and the uh the british
that's what you end up with northern
ireland that's why you were there that's
yeah
all right uh oh let's read the news and
talk about the kamala harris and then
these other stories before we do
head over to timcast.com and click the
members only button to become a member
of teamguest.com
and then you get access to the members
only area last week we had a really uh
great discussion with
almost an hour long me and sheamus we
were talking about uh pro
pro life pro choice and all these things
and uh people are really getting into
the comments so if you want to check
that out go there but also um
we're about a week or two away from the
launch of our newsroom
which will be rudimentary at first but
uh we're gonna be bringing on
journalists and
what i will be doing when you become a
member here's what happens the money
it goes to funding this operation of
which is going to
there's going to be on the ground
reporters we're going to have
you know standard newsroom reporting
fact checking we're starting with one
reporter and a few
contract reporters then we're going to
have probably a fact checker
and we're already at the point where i
am trying to contract
out documentary production news dispatch
production
so we are there baby we're ready to go
and so and now it's just a matter of uh
i guess hiring the people who can
oversee this
so the first person we hire is probably
going to oversee budgeting for
sending out crews to go on the ground go
to these various cities during conflict
right just like the riot squad does but
we'll have our own crew that does it
and a fact checking network so that's
that's what that's what your membership
gets
so for you you need to watch all this
great content but more importantly
you're helping us build this site
because the new site's gonna be
launching really soon
check it out become a member don't
forget to like this video subscribe to
this channel
share the show with your friends if you
think we do a good job i'm thinking in
the next couple of weeks you guys are
going to be really excited and impressed
and we're going to get all the shares
everything's like this is great we need
more of this we need more field
reporting
and we're definitely going to be funding
undercover and investigative reporting
which is going to cause a lot of
controversy and
i don't know maybe eventually get us
banned on the internet we'll see what
happens but uh let's jump into it i
actually can can i say something there
when you mentioned fact checking it
reminded me i actually need to fact
check myself i got a fact wrong on our
last show
or two shows ago i said the us has more
economic mobility than any other
developed nation that's not true it's
it's higher than most people think so
like 12 percent of people will be in the
top 1
at some point 56 percent of people will
be in the top 10 percent the income
brackets are really fluid but we don't
have the most economic mobility so i was
incorrect about that
um i i'd have to double check i just
know it's not us once i look back into
it yeah
yeah that's my mistake if i make a
mistake i want to uh i want to clear it
up i don't want to spread misinformation
so
oh man tim's kicking me out
because you go from peasant to party you
go down really fast
no yeah yeah downward mobility
let's talk about what's going on
guatemala we got the story from the new
york post
guatemala's president blames biden for
border crisis as
protesters tell kamala harris that trump
won
this is this is amazing these photos go
home come
go home kamala mind your own business
and a big sign that says kamala trump
won
that that is crazy i didn't expect this
i would have thought
i actually no i take that back this
makes a whole lot of sense the people
who are
staying in guatemala probably like what
trump's policies are towards you know
guatemala and
what they should and shouldn't be doing
the people who are leaving guatemala
they're not going to like trump right
that makes sense yeah
because trump's the guy's blocking them
from trying to get into the u.s so
naturally the people who remain are like
yeah go trump
well and you sort of touched on this
earlier but the messaging that the biden
administration is sending to people who
might be considering migrating to the us
is so mixed the kamala goes down there
and she says
if you if you're thinking of coming here
illegally don't even try it because you
will not be welcome
if you're one of the illegal immigrants
who's already here one of the 11 million
plus we're already here you know you're
going to be naturalized
and we're going to give you citizenship
because there needs to be a path for
citizenship because anything else would
be inhumane
but you're not welcome to come here if
you're not here it's insane
this is one of the biggest problems of
this administration okay because because
i want to do that check do we have
biden derangement syndrome no yeah no we
don't
check it out dallas news reports vp
harris in guatemala says border visit
would be mere grand gesture
warns migrants do not come okay come on
i mean yeah look maybe
gesture fine whatever trump went down
and surveyed a lot of the border
it was it was a big issue he knows the
american people were concerned about he
went
i think about this like you know trump
derangement syndrome or abundant
arrangement syndrome thing and i'm like
i honestly i think
it really does in many ways come down to
a difference in opinion based on
what is what what deserves priority
and so i think there's a lot of people
who are like liberals leftists
mostly liberals leftists at your
difference base liberals who are just
like
i don't care all that much about illegal
immigration i just don't
and so republicans do and then the left
is like why aren't you talking about
january 6 and republicans don't they're
like because it was a right
so it really is like a difference of
opinion that there's no
obviously in media there's a lot of
fact-based problems where the left or
the right believe different things
but i think a lot of it's just
subjective morality i don't think
january 6 was the apocalypse i think it
was a riot i think it was bad
i think it was you know it was serious
but not the apocalypse like they're
putting out to be what did anderson
cooper say
you see what he said oh well no no i i
was that's the worst
attack on this country since 9 11 oh
civil war wow
that is hardcore wow jfk getting
assassinated sure
but i mean so i hear what you say about
people putting different emphasis on
different issues based on where they
are in the political spectrum but the
biden administration's
messaging on this has been very confused
sometimes they're saying things that are
very like warm and friendly and open to
people who want to come here and then
other times it's well you're not welcome
so like
biden putting a moratorium on
deportations
and then kamala going down and saying
illegal immigrants are not welcome here
to me seems
ridiculously conflicting regardless of
how you feel about illegal immigration
as an issue
it's a fun house mirror of policy
because early on in his campaign and
even you know
biden got blocked from doing this but
biden was like we're gonna put a
moratorium on deportations come on man
and then you know he gets in and he no
now they've officially ended as of june
1st the remain in mexico policy
which was donald trump's policy that
said if you come to the border
we'll process your asylum while you
remain in mexico so they officially
ended that now they're doing catch and
release
so people are they're once again
encouraging people to come in
they catch them let them go in fact joe
biden his administration has been
smuggling migrant children into
different states in the dead of night
which is one of the creepiest things
i've ever heard now
here's the fun house mirror because now
kamala harris says do not come right
that's funny like a week ago biden
announced he was increasing the amount
of refugees and asylums they would allow
into the united states
so biden's like we're going to increase
the amount of people that we allow in
and then comma goes but don't come
yeah exactly they're going to be like
nah i'll come and biden's going to let
me in
what that's the thing this is sort of
what i was touching on a little bit
earlier i don't know if i
articulated it quite well enough but to
say we need to naturalize all of the
illegal immigrants who are already here
but then turn around and say none of you
should cross the border though
to me is completely pointless of course
they're going to come over here like
what are you saying
you're you're welcoming them you're
inviting them even if not with your
words with then with your actions but
but i kind of feel like that's part of
it you know kamala harris can go she
won't go to the border
all right that's serious that she's
showing she's not serious
right it's just a gesture tim right it's
it's not a priority for her
and that's what i was saying like i
think a lot of democrats are just like
who cares i think
people like kamala she's thinking about
is this going to get me votes
the answer is no because the democratic
base
they were the ones that want to open
borders they were the ones that on the
debate stage
that the moderator i can't remember was
how many of you are in favor of giving
universal health care to illegal
immigrants or legally
and they all raise their hand my
favorite as a democrats who like kind of
look around like is this what we're
about now they're like really
okay all right guys i guess yeah so so i
think kamal is just like i don't care
it's like i know some people are
bothered by it so i gotta say something
but she's not gonna say much
meanwhile the actual policies are making
the problem worse
and uh oh yeah this is crazy uh lady
just pulled this up the denver gazette
republican wins mayoral race in majority
hispanic mcallen texas
mcallen is where they expanded the
detention center they have kids sleeping
in dirt
big issues so i if you look at south
texas if you look at miami dude remember
uh during 2020 election there was a safe
blue district in miami
flipped red yeah that was that was crazy
it's because
what did this guy say he said something
about communism was being bad
i don't know maybe it wasn't this guy
but these areas
like south texas majority hispanic they
do not like illegal immigration
and i have to imagine because a lot of
these hard-working americans people who
came here illegally
are working and they're seeing what's
happening
and he was correct i actually had a
friend who came from chihuahua and she
told me that her parents told
her that she was going to do it legally
so that people would respect her
she did not like illegal immigrants
she's like they just come here it's easy
for them they get everything they want
i worked so hard and they're just taking
advantage of this system and it's it's
literally the system i'm now paying into
it's
out there i would imagine i don't know
for sure but like if you're in a big
city the illegal immigrants that are
there are already
kind of assimilated like they have jobs
sort of but the ones on the border are
like
random people that just got over here
maybe you don't even have any intention
of going to a city to get work
they just want to avoid the the chaos of
south africa i don't know
biden's been sending migrant kids in the
dead of night to various
states yeah they're they're they're
shipping uh these illegal immigrants
into like ohio
and then having them detained by the
local police they're like oh
we we detained these these illegal these
illegal immigrants so we need the police
you know in ohio to hold them
then once they say okay cut them loose
and they release them directly into
their community it's spreading them out
all across the country
it is the weirdest the weirdest thing
now i have a question though in the
story about kamala and like the
protesters
who's the racist one oh man that's rough
okay well here's what we'd have to
figure out tim we need to do
an analysis on the crowd and figure out
how many are men and how many are women
because kamal is a woman of color
right if most of the people in the crowd
are women to the point we could say the
crowd is represented by women then
it's kind of a toss-up but if the crowd
is mostly male
in fact it doesn't even matter right if
there's any men in the crowd then the
crowd is somewhat male
so kamala has to be the victim here no
based on the rules of intersectionality
you've got math planned for this
exactly i know what's up yeah so no no
but but
i guess the serious question is like i
think one of the reasons you're not
going to see this story
prominently on the left is just that it
makes no sense for the narrative
like a third world country or however
they would describe it minority country
saying they like trump better oh mcallen
texas they flip
they flip republican south texas
district miami flip trump flip trump
guatemala we like trump better yeah i'm
not saying everybody in guatemala likes
trump better
but it's it's he's going to run there
he's like going
about it i'll be confident then he
becomes president of guatemala just
takes over the united states
what dude it's trump
because i i could do it i get the job
done
if anyone could it's him he just 100
approval in guatemala and then
annexes the neighboring countries starts
in neighboring countries until he gets
the united states so yeah
i can see trump just going for it right
from guatemala he's like we could we're
good
i don't i don't know uh what the average
worker is supposed to think about this
kind of uh
this kind of thing i i love that uh
people around the world
are are invested in the politics the
united states to the point where they're
going to complain
i mean that's that's awesome to me this
is global this is way beyond i mean
kindness
i kind of like when people aren't that
invested in our politics and don't
comment on it if i'm completely honest
yeah why is it that
so many places around the world are
obsessed with america i think because of
hollywood
haters because they ain't us we got like
the cultural hub of the world in
hollywood we have the fiscal
um not really the kind of the fiscal hub
of the world with the u.s federal
reserve in the us dollar that's kind of
the bank of england i mean we have the
federal we have the world reserve
currency the swiss bank it's kind of
coming out of switzerland but we're like
the spearhead
so the world looks at us as like the
financial centerpiece and the
cultural centerpiece not us necessarily
but this country i think it's movies
that when you look at what when you look
at what hollywood is churning out i get
why the world hates us
it's like you understand i don't even
think it's our foreign policy i really
think it's all
i'm being facetious here no no it's like
in that vox article from uh i think like
a year ago or two years ago
yeah i think it was two years ago now
where they they asked one of the
migrants in the caravan why they were
coming to america and the guy said i
miss buffalo wild wings yeah
i'm like buffalo wild wings is like
there's a bunch in mexico you know like
these people yeah the restaurant i mean
i love b-dubs too
it's just not as good there though i
can't remember less i don't know oh
b-dubs is
bw3s is buffalo wild wings buffalo wild
wings i didn't know that's what bw stood
for
b-dubs bw3s what is it that was a bw
if it's like w to the third power like
i don't think you're talking about the
same buffalo sauce which is
french red hot and that's like the
secret ingredient buffalo wild
sauce anyway dude yeah you're talking
about a restaurant
yes i'm talking about these people who
are walking through mexico
and the reporters like why are you walk
why won't you stay in mexico and the
guy's like i miss
buffalo wild wings and i'm like dude
it's right there in mexico city i went
there
no joke i went to the mexico city
buffalo wildlings it was great
it's wonderful i mean this is like
like why are you going back to chicago
i've missed portillos
i didn't go to chicago for that but you
order it you ordered it man it's
fantastic true that's why i come here
someone someone in the audience asked if
i was kidnapped actually tim just has
portillos
no but i think when it comes to these
migrants they're they're watching
american tv commercials movies
and so their whole perception of reality
is based upon american cities and stuff
this is also a great place to live it is
it's awesome in many ways i mean
it's going downhill unfortunately
especially with the kind of thing the
kinds of things we've been tolerating
over the past year and a half
uh particularly though those are
probably more of a symptom of
the issues we've been tolerating for
much longer than that but yeah america
is a great place okay
yeah we've got beat ups we've got
buffalo wild wings that's right it's
like
going sledding yeah we're going downhill
how many times do we say buffalo
wildlings so far
i don't know they should be paying you
i'm supposed to say it five times we're
just
wasting the name five times did the
quaker stake in lube
on the dude we showed you the border of
ohio and pennsylvania best wings place
in the world
or in the united states what time i
don't know i think that's going to
change places
like sauces get sponsorship deals with
all sorts of food places where we'll be
discussing something political and then
ian turns it over to some kind of food
and we have to explain a restaurant too
yeah that'll be just a brilliant
marketing scene because people think
it's authentic yeah
it would be funny if we actually had
just like 50 sponsors per show
and uh we've got this this big story
from nbc news
supreme court unanimously rules against
immigrants with temporary status
man that's all almost as shocking as the
delicious flavor of the popeye's chicken
sandwich
i'm just kidding i honestly couldn't
this is but when i tasted it
this is a throwback joke for the people
watching who have no idea what's
happening
oh no but let's jump to the story just
this is nine to zero this is crazy
uh supreme court unanimously rules
against immigrants
if they enter the country illegally and
they have temporary protected status
they cannot get green cards i just
here's what i love about this and i
appreciate it that it says in this it's
just kind of a funny headline that it
says the supreme court unanimously rules
against
immigrants with temporary status and
then right below okay like illegal
immigrants
and then at the very very very bottom of
the article in the last paragraph
monday's decision does not affect
immigrants with tps who initially
entered the us legally
it's like so it's so the the headline
literally is immigrants but this is what
they're doing
they're they're they're they've been
consistently conflating illegal
immigrants with immigrants
for years for years why
because it's an easier it's an easy way
to win the discussion like who wants to
say they're against them it's much
easier to say you're against illegal
immigration you don't like when people
break the rules and they come into your
country despite the fact that your
nation
has set up certain parameters for
someone entering so that we can monitor
who's coming in and they've decided to
disobey those rules
that's reasonable how could you disagree
with that but
if you say that those people are just
mean haters who don't like immigration
in general
so it keeps dumb people in check because
anybody anybody who actually
discussion yeah anyone who can actually
read this and discern what's happening
knows
they're not talking about immigrants who
enter the country legally and they're
not talking about refugees
that's a big difference is a refugee and
an illegal immigrant
if someone's fleeing hostility we have a
duty
to take them in i think you know most
people do
there's limits yeah within limitations
so you don't destroy your own system but
exactly illegal immigration is not it's
not that well
and this is the point right yes we
should be helping people who need our
help but
the well-being of the people already
living in the country needs to be taken
into account there has to be some kind
of balancing act but if you support
unrestricted illegal immigration what
you're saying is that balancing act
doesn't matter as many people can flood
this country as want to without there
being any oversight and if you disagree
with that you're a hater
in the way they convince people of that
is by framing it as a discussion of
people who are pro-immigrant or
anti-immigrant rather than
people who are illegal immigration and
pro following the law
bro there's there is a a chaotic
destructive entity hacking away at the
roots of this nation
and it's it's hard to even say that we
remain a nation
i know a lot of people on the left will
immediately they attack this idea if you
come out
and you say that we are at risk of not
being a country anymore
the left will immediately start
attacking you why it's true it's a
vulnerable
vulnerable spot for them let's think
about a few things the democrats in the
debate stage
in last year in the in the in the year
prior in the election cycle
raised their hand to give
taxpayer-funded medical care
to non-citizens california's actually
done it
you've got democratic interests and
media
conflating illegal immigration with
legal immigration why because they
they want it you've got the same
ideology this woke
group literally rewriting american
history the 1619 project
now it's being resisted but when you
like we mentioned this last week but
when you've got
people rewriting history and teaching in
schools a re we've totally revised
american history now washington state
this this was jason rantz reported this
is mandating critical race theory
so you know they're teaching kids fake
american history what's gonna happen
these kids are gonna grow up and they're
gonna be like america was founded in
1619 as a slaveocracy
and you're gonna be like that's made up
we know it's made up we actually had
debunkers and news
doesn't matter they teach it to the kids
20 years from now they'll say i know
what's true you're
lying that's my reality so now the
history of this country is
is under attack the embassies are flying
flags that
ideology the people who are pushing that
ideology and politically
are trying to flood the country they're
saying illegal immigration and
immigration are the exact same thing
legal immigration is fantastic i think
it's great we get a lot of high skilled
work
we we basically when we have legal
immigration
in many instances i was reading this
this uh story about it
there's like a good portion of those who
immigrate legally are high skilled
workers
and then a good portion are low skilled
workers but the high skilled workers are
bringing their innovation their
technology
their resources and ideas into the us
it's great for us
illegal immigration not so much it's bad
for everybody it creates a massive
supply of of a workforce at the lower
level making work
so you you have a massive supply and
limited demand for low skilled labor
making it more difficult for people in
america
overall it's just very bad for lower
income individuals
they're they're conflating these things
they're claiming that
you know the right are the ones
destroying democracy that are attacking
attacking democracy
if this keeps going this direction and i
think it likely will because republicans
don't do anything about it republicans
engage in the conversation the democrats
decide they do
then in 20 years there will not be a
united states as we know it
the history is going to be 16 19 and
there's going to be a complete
shift in in demographics in every
different place especially with biden
you know shuffling immigrant children
illegal immigrant children all across
the country
it is going to erode at our civic
institutions
and i think that's one of the big
reasons democrats keep saying democracy
and why they've been saying it for a
long time
we're not a democracy we've never been a
democracy we have democratic
institutions like our
electoral process but we are
constitutional republic democracy makes
it easier to subvert the will of
you know of the citizens so now we're
going to be entering a period where
yeah your money's going to get stripped
away from you joe biden is
is putting an invisible tax on the
working class and the lower class in a
variety of ways
and it continues to just eat away at the
united states
and what's going to be done about it i
mean there's a resistance but a
resistance is not a reversal
so we can talk about this we can vote
for certain poli p for certain
individuals
but in the end you get republicans who
agree with the framing from the
democrats
agree with them in the long run and in
ten years the republicans will
completely be completely aligned with
the
work with where the democrats are today
and the democrats will move
continually in this other direction
until what
yeah i mean the entire vote falls apart
and i've said that i hope i'm not
starting to sound like a broken record
on these points but i've said this in
the past
i mean leftism is just social decay
transformed into an ideological system
of thought
and so it almost seems inevitable but on
the other hand i think we can turn this
around
i think you're absolutely right that all
republicans or conservatives are trying
to do is resist instead of putting
forward an ideology of their own and
that's a huge part of why they're losing
and i'll sound like a broken record
again but this is also why i believe
like fundamentally conservatism has to
be rooted
in catholicism you have to have values
that you're forwarding you can't just
say
x y and z that the left is trying to do
are bad but we're not going to give you
a coherent system of thought
that should replace that or which is
undergird or excuse me undergirding our
present system
that we should stick to yeah republicans
aren't against things democrats are for
things yeah yeah exactly
exactly and if and if that's the case
then you're gonna get a bunch of
leftists saying we want this
and republicans saying slow down and
that's it and then eventually they get
what they want
now i think the trump era trump
supporters want things
and they're demanding exactly and so
that was a problem for the left
i guess the issue is if you live in the
blue-pilled reality of the democrats
you know the republicans are smart
snarling demons who have ultimate power
and everything's their fault when they
could barely get anything done
the left frames everything the democrats
frame everything as
if we don't get what we want republicans
are evil
the republicans aren't even asking for
anything
so it's basically them saying we've got
a bunch of what we want we want more
what the republicans are evil for not
giving us more of what we want
yeah exactly there is there is no
pushback for the most part from the
republican party
except for these new these new trump
republicans trump himself
that was a problem for all of us and the
democrats because
the democrats are obstinate they will
not stop they will not shut up they will
not back
down finally you get republicans willing
to fight back
and then it's an unstoppable force and
an immovable object eventually it's just
there's going to be a a fracturing of
the united states
i wonder if this ultimately is just uh
where it comes from is it a a
psychological operation are we under
attack are we being manipulated
you know what i mean yeah we we i'm not
sure i don't i don't think that it's uh
i keep thinking about the roman empire
um when they it seems like things are so
stable here but then it also seems like
we kind of don't have a culture in the
united states we've got like so many
cultures
that it's like how do you pinpoint what
we are as a nation we have the
constitution
that's very basic the roman empire
people would migrate
in and it was very dangerous when people
would come in because what would happen
is they'd migrate in
nothing would happen then their friends
and family would come migrate in and all
of a sudden you'd have like a hundred
thousand people in a city from another
country and they'd overthrow the mayor
and take control of the city yeah and
then
the state the surrounding lands so that
is very real
with immigration that's why you have to
be careful about your borders
and about letting too many people of
different cultures that don't value the
constitution the government
necessarily can you imagine if like 170
000 people poured over the border of a
country and then the president of that
country
released a video welcoming people and
thanking them for choosing his country
why didn't that literally happen in
march at the end of march yeah in march
170 000 people was a 15-year high
in terms of people spilling over the
border and binder released a video
granted it was for
people who are being naturalized as
citizens but what he says is thank you
for choosing america
it takes a lot of courage to cross over
that border and come to this nation etc
so
it's just setting us up for destruction
ultimately very yeah and it would be it
would be one thing if he was saying that
to people
because he he he was speaking to people
who are becoming citizens but the
problem is when you release that kind of
messaging
at a time when the left is insistent
upon conflating
immigration and illegal immigration you
are basically giving the okay to
everyone who wants to come into this
country illegally to do so
with this mixed messaging that they've
been giving now is like if you're here
we're gonna we're gonna
say it's okay but don't come it's
basically like saying
but if you get here and no one knows
then we're going to treat you like
you're fine
exactly so that's insane it's insane
it's a it's completely insane
unless it is their intention to get as
many people here as possible and then
naturalize them
and then build a loyalty in a
relationship between those people in
their political party so that they win
forever i'm not entitled to that perfect
that would happen
maybe it wouldn't and i hope it wouldn't
but i think that if there is a plan
that's it look at uh south texas mcallen
we were talking about this i mean
hispanic areas flipped they're going
republican
and i think that's fantastic and there
are many conservatives who predicted
that that kind of thing would happen
because i think mexican people tend to
be more socially conservative and that's
where most immigrants are coming from
but that's definitely not something the
left has been banking on
yeah the left has sort of assumed that
they own immigrants in immigration and
they tend to believe that they can
depend upon virtually every minority
group to support them
i'm just uh man i'm i i don't know if i
have confidence
in the current opposition to
what the democrats and left have been
doing to believe
that we are headed down a path where we
can preserve our values free speech
i think uh for one and um the right to
bear arms obviously
but more just like uh our moral
framework and
our uh our our values as a nation
when you get a bunch of people who
aren't from here who come in
it's mostly just about a nice place to
live it's not about the values of the
country that's why
when you take the the citizenship test
they ask you you have to learn the
history of the country
they want to you to know and respect
this country and what it represents
who the presidents were and things like
that when people come here illegally
they don't know or care about any of
that
they're just coming and saying here's my
chance you know to to to get some
resources
now the left's response is usually like
oh it's no big deal you won't even
notice and
it's just absurd to think that there's
not going to be an impact you mean to
tell me that when it comes to climate
change
you know all of these farting cows and
all these individuals using
electricity and air conditioning it's
extremely bad
you mean to tell me that the individual
has an impact on on climate change
but the individual coming in here
illegally doesn't have an impact on our
economy
how about we frame it that way right the
united states produces more carbon
emissions than a bunch of other
countries so the last thing we want is
more americans right
no i guess they're they're fine with
that they want to transform the economy
as well
so what do you what do you mean you tell
me you're going to invite 170 000 people
in one month but then also take away
their means of actually maintaining
themselves through the economy
they can't use electricity they can't
produce carbon then all you're doing is
encouraging them to go on these long and
dangerous journeys then once they get
here
you make them do surf labor in exchange
for for nothing but limited access to
resources
meanwhile the ultra rich are allowed to
do whatever whatever they want yeah
exactly
you're kind of building a an underclass
and
there's a few things you said there
which i'd like to dive into when you're
talking about immigration it's sort of
the distinction between illegal
immigration and legal immigration
there are a number of people who have
made the criticisms that well you know a
lot of conservatives
say that they're in favor of immigration
but they're against illegal immigration
but that's incoherent because
then they should be okay with us
allowing anyone into this country as
long as we make them a naturalized
citizen through some kind of process
but the entire purpose of having an
immigration system is as i said earlier
oversight and so i think what we need to
be doing in terms of our messaging isn't
just saying we are against illegal
immigration we have to be talking about
the immigration system which we want to
build
or the one which was supposed to be here
which we would like to maintain and that
is one which says
if somebody wants to come here as you
stated they have to prove to us
that they are interested in promoting
our values did you know that john
stewart
once uh a few years ago six years ago or
seven years ago advocated for the draft
whoa jon stewart said volunteer work
bring back the news to the draft i think
he said like draft people into doing
volunteer work though
well he said for the greater good of the
country yes he said the draft that he
said but it could be
you know what you know what he i could
simplify his entire quote down to a very
simple sentence
service guarantees citizenship oh john
stewart endorsed he didn't say that
though okay
but that was basically what he was
saying it would give people a skin in
the game mistake
i agree but i agree with jon stewart
about his statements on
the draft but here's here's where it
gets complicated service guarantees
citizenship
the problem is i mean there is already a
kind of service which is taking place
when people come into this country
they're
doing jobs not that americans aren't
willing to do but that americans aren't
willing to do as inexpensively as they
will do them
and so they're already providing a
service but the problem is at some point
you over saturate the market and make
life more difficult for people who are
already here so that's why i would be a
bit apprehensive about that even if they
are coming here and providing some kind
of service at some point
we still reach a limit where there are
too many people and no matter how badly
someone wants to come here and serve we
just can't let them
could you imagine if the u.s said like
literally anybody serve two years in the
armed forces as like front line infantry
and you'll get citizenship oh my
goodness
that's roman style yeah yeah the us
would have like a million ground
troops every year added to their ranks
so they don't do it exactly like that
it would be that that's a pretty evil
thing in my opinion well yeah and it
would also
i would imagine you mentioned the romans
at this but i would imagine that would
be a really horrible military strategy
because you have a bunch of people who
aren't committed to the ideas of your
nation and don't necessarily have any
loyalty to it and now they're on the
front lines of your military
yeah but those people could be
completely anti-america and they could
just be infiltrating your armed forces
but it's a it's the zapp brannigan
strategy you know if we get into a
full-scale conflict with another nation
and you you can just send wave after
wave of your own yeah very evil
yeah yeah yeah but uh i i
think think about the so the reason i
brought that up is i'm thinking about
the erosion of the united states and
what this means moving forward and
here's what freaks me out all right
we got the story here this one
from forbes anticipating war with china
the u.s air force is fanning out across
the pacific
so the u.s air force is concerned that
china a chinese rocket attack would wipe
out two of our most prominent air force
bases
so we are dispatching all of these
different squadrons to different
airports and different islands all
across the pacific so we have rapid
response
we've decentralized so they can't just
take us out it's got this gets me
worried because
we have another story here i covered
this last week june 1st pentagon eyes
new bombs for war with china not isis
the pentagon's been shifting up its
strategy no longer are we engaging in
preparations for war in the middle east
you know there's a report saying we're
like halfway out of afghanistan
and now the bombs they're buying are for
pacific warfare and not
middle eastern warfare and it could just
be
we're all done middle east is over we
got enough oil
we've built enough nation we're out and
because of that well we might as well
buy bombs for pacific because that's a
bigger threat right
or it could be that we're actually
gearing up towards a war with china
now here's what freaks me out the u.s is
in is is in chaos man
i mean maybe we're not maybe it's all an
illusion but come on you look at
news they're screaming on insurrection
anderson cooper claiming
january 6 was worst the worst political
attack on the u.s since the civil war
and i'm like
i seem to recall john f kennedy getting
his head blown off but
okay dude whatever you say that's it
that's insanity what happens right now
if china moves in on taiwan and the u.s
can do
nothing to stop it there it is
i mean we have to stand by there's no
way i i don't think i would ever
authorize
the arms against china to defend taiwan
not unless it was our soil
or like an ally or something i mean i
mean they're an ally they are an ally
so this is where things get bad because
if china does move in taiwan and there's
serious fear in the u.s
that they they are planning an invasion
i mean we see the beaching drills
there's photos of it
and uh their planes are flying over the
town straight they're sending strike
groups through the strait of taiwan
it's not just about taiwan it's about
china's incursions into the south china
sea it's about their military bases
their expansion their violation of
certain international conventions
so the fear i have is the u.s is clearly
preparing for war
china they've been gearing up for some
time this is a more direct announcement
what this says to me is do you think the
u.s military just decided right now
that they're worried about war with
china do you think it was just like
today they're like
hey yo there might be china let's move
our planes or
is it more likely they got intelligence
classified
about a potential war with china made a
bunch of crazy economic moves behind the
scenes
and then made the public moves everyone
can see could be
china also said i think i heard from you
that china was like threaten nuclear war
if we tried to investigate
well in response to biden's call for an
investigation into covid
the head of global times said we need to
start building more nuclear bombs and to
shiver down the spine of the the
american illegal okay yeah that's
i think which is another way of saying
we are innocent
[Laughter]
and obviously the incursions the hong
kong the way they treated the
yeah the protesters in hong kong was was
drastic uh i think
i fear i think we're in trouble man joe
biden didn't commemorate d-day um
really why not i don't know i don't i
i don't i look here here's one of the
issues he finally didn't know what day
it was
oh that's for sure that's not even a
joke
i was kidding because obviously people
in his administration would no one make
some kind of announcement tell him to do
it
hey or tweet for him yeah now here's one
of the problems i don't know
every year every tweet that's ever been
sent out or every statement's ever been
made about d-day it could just be
that now we're in this deeply tribal
political realm conservatives noticed
biden didn't do this brought it up then
everyone's like hey yeah why didn't you
and it's like well i don't know maybe
jimmy carter didn't i don't know
or maybe he still should have regardless
he didn't and a lot of other people did
maybe kamala harris saying enjoy the
long weekend is also an alarming
statement maybe kamala is refusing
harris for fees and go to the border is
also kind of alarming
and it makes me feel like our current
administration is not invested in this
country
i feel like we have an administration
that in a normal timeline
shouldn't have have won but we aren't in
a normal timeline
what i mean by this is normally you get
a strong administration that wants to
win
that wants a policy that wants to put
things forward and make these demands
well that was trump's administration man
did he want some crazy stuff a big
beautiful wall from sea to shining sea
thirty feet concrete
he had plans he wanted things biden
his whole campaign was that he was not
trump
so what happens people really didn't
like trump
a lot of things happen we'll see what
happens with his maricopa stuff joe
biden ends up uh
you know getting 81 million votes he
wins the election with no plan
no one voted for anything they just
didn't want trump
now we have an administration that
clearly doesn't care so i want to say a
normal timeline
they weren't proposing anything
substantive other joe biden was hiding
the whole time
he was just like hiding in the basement
everyone's like where's bye no call to
call
you know he's a lid yeah call in a lid
yeah no press
so this is what you get now we're we're
we're facing the very serious prospect
of war with china
our military seems to think so and
what can we expect in the event that war
actually breaks out my fear is that war
will come to us no matter what we do
and this is a fear that a lot of people
have in government and it leads to very
pro-war sentiment which i disagree with
but
the world is not so black and white you
can't just be like i'm against war so we
therefore i will never go to war and
it's like then you get wiped out
no i mean i understand that i'm i'm very
anti-war the number of wars that i would
be willing to support
um let's just say it's it's an extremely
narrow subset
that said this is a really complicated
situation i'm not going to sit here and
automatically say there's nothing that
could ever justify that i very much do
not want to see
war with china but this is an extremely
complicated situation
let's talk yeah conspiracy oh no
oh well this is also i mean obviously we
should do everything we possibly can to
avoid that war if at all possible i'm
not coming down on one side or the other
i'm being the milktoast fencer here but
it's also because i just
i haven't um most of my interest in
foreign policy has been directed towards
the middle east because that's where the
united states has been screwing around
for the past two decades
but uh when it comes to china i guess i
i just hadn't really considered that it
was a realistic possibility until very
recently
so you opposed war with china what
you oppose war with china uh yeah i
would like not to go to war with china
but also i have no idea i mean there
could be reasons that someone brings to
my attention yeah i'm not dogmatic i
just wanted to clarify
okay so my position is you know i don't
want to go with go to war with china but
the war may come to us either way
so i'm i'm a bit more in the middle than
you that means ian you have to take the
pro-war with china's position i'm
obsessed kidding
i'm kidding yeah well ian's always
telling me oh wake up
i'm sweating right now dude every single
day every single day i see
ian sitting on the couch just cleaning
his ar he's like
we're getting ready we're getting ready
you're all laughing at me he
knits he knits wool chinese flags
and then he brings him out and he puts
him on the archery board and oh my god
no i'm kidding
but uh no let's talk about uh conspiracy
it's not not really a conspiracy
conspiracy it's a weird word conspiracy
can i ask you something what do you so
what do you think would have to happen
um to justify a war with china from your
perspective or what do you think
would put you over the edge where you
would say like we we have no choice i
don't know man
i mean usually it's like china beaching
on california in california yeah that's
kind of what i'm saying like
start to invade and there's nothing else
we can do but
yeah but it's more than that like if if
we
if we sit back and this is this is a
really tough philosophical question
and just let them do whatever they want
exactly exactly make them get totally
stronger so it's like you sit back and
you're like china's building
a new gps system to rival the us's
because we have the main gps amused by
everybody
they're going to become militaristically
independent
they're sure they're taking in more
imports than exports
they're doing beaching drills for taiwan
they're trying to seize the south china
sea they're sinking vietnamese fishing
boats they're building military bases in
violation of international conventions
and they just keep doing it what happens
if we do nothing
double keep doing it and then eventually
once all our allies are crushed and our
resources are limited
then they land their boats on our
beaches and we say well
the one thing we got going for us we got
a gun behind every plate of grass yeah
exactly you know we are a nation
armed to the teeth so they will never i
don't think it's possible to conquer
america
no i just don't think it's physical like
you could literally conquer california
yeah like everywhere else it'd be really
hard no i i don't i mean i'm being
facetious
it'd be difficult to take any scrap of
land on this country on this yeah
yeah like you would you would have you
would have confederate flag waving
you know republicans from the
the you know i don't want to say deep
south but i don't know because it's not
really
running over to california the
californians you'd be like no you need
to leave no like we'd rather have the
chinese here no
no there would there would be soy boys
cowering with their you know purple
mohawk going like they're shooting at me
and it's like don't worry
you're american i may not like you at
all but
we're being invaded no like you'll get
the staunchest conservatives waving you
know confederate flags
running into battle and defending the
california soyboys
but so so there there's the really
really serious problem about war with
china
it's really easy to be like i'm anti-war
exactly
it is now that's easy to say we're
talking about syria in the middle east
oh i get it you want to build an oil
pipeline what did biden do
biden just approved russia to build the
pipeline anyway
so that is the saw conspiracies okay
i've been trying to i'm trying you guys
won't let me you want to take it i
always every single day
tim just just sends me these articles
and i have to send them some nopes
factions
is that true i have brought sheamus like
15 gay frogs and he
keeps telling me to shut up i just you
don't that frog is it's expressing
itself a certain way that doesn't
have anything to do with the chemicals
in the water or anything to do with that
frog's orientation
here's what i mean i don't mean like
conspiracies i say that because
it's funny how they've turned that word
into something that means like
false stories so what like when people
talk about flat earth like it's a
conspiracy theory no no no no no
if you believe in stupid things that's
just you believing in stupid things but
let me say this
last year the economy's locked down what
happened
a bunch of people in our major our major
urban hubs
moved and they moved to random places we
can't
like they didn't well the half a million
people who left new york they didn't
just move
from like new york to like pittsburgh so
they spread all over the place
now these are the people of means these
are heads of industry
these are wealthy individuals who
command economics who command the
economy in this country they
decentralized
what else happened we realized we
couldn't manufacture things we had no
capability
we tried shoring up our manufacturing
now we have a bipartisan bill democrats
republicans agree
we need 250 billion dollars towards
industry in the united states
i think about these things the
decentralization of our our economy
the moving out of cities i mean that's
really fortunate for us should we enter
war with china buying guns
if buying guns like firearms the riots
made people buy guns like crazy
yeah if a nuke dropped on new york last
year
beginning of last year it would wipe out
tons of heads of industry
it would destroy our economy the
pandemic resulted in
a decentralization so i don't really
mean conspiracy i'm just saying
how fortuitous for us in the event a war
breaks out
these things happened we got more people
are armed to the teeth
in in cities in california more people
have left big cities and moved out to
suburbs and moved out to rural areas
and they're working remote all these
things are
really good news for a countryman to go
to war you know the downside of working
remote is you're you're at the whim of
the electric grid which could be a
problem if that gets knocked out
but other than that i think you're right
man a big push to get off fossil fuels
you know and to get
solar energy and renewables and so this
is something i've been telling myself
maybe it's just to cope because i'm very
sad but ammo has been ridiculously
expensive for the past year and a half
and
anyone who has any interest in firearms
knows that and when i see the prices i
get very sad when i see the empty
shelves i'm sad
but what that means is that more
americans than ever before have
ammunition i mean the reason the demand
skyrocketed is because everyone out went
out and bought ammo and that means the
american public is now significantly
better armed
than they were prior to covet and i
think that's fantastic
i was buying i think i was buying 380
and it was like a dollar around or
something insane
i'm just i'm just that's insane yeah i
wonder what it's at now
i mean ammo isn't it i you know i've
been talking about like a good
investment and everyone's like you got
to buy this you got to buy that i'm like
you know i thought about it what i said
i've been saying for a while think about
the most common
household item that's the hardest to
produce
and that's probably a good investment
because in in a when if
assuming there's like a major crisis or
a war or something
otherwise if the economy is going to
keep on keeping on the way it is without
ups and downs and you know quantitative
easing yeah well then you've got your
standard gold bitcoin whatever
but i'm talking about in the event of a
war or some kind of conflict of crisis
what's a good investment
and so i think you know like mouthwash
really really good
you can use antiseptic you know you can
use it to clean your mouth
really great you don't want to get you
know infected teeth or any or anything
that can kill you
but more importantly like if you get a
cut just it's antiseptic and use it so
alcohol works but alcohol you can't you
don't want to put in your mouth right
so hydrogen peroxide what's hard to
produce but iodine
really important yeah iodine chlorine
that's been
so these simple household chemicals that
we use all the time
for cleaning for for helping ourselves
those are probably good investments but
i thought about this like
if you're going to park your money in in
anything
in in in in fear of some kind of
conflict what would be a good place to
do it
water yeah people need water gasoline
uh gasoline doesn't stay yeah gasoline
i don't know how this would work for a
large supply but i know that there are
uh powders that you can put in gasoline
to make it last longer make it stay
longer
yeah but um there's other fuels you can
but i thought about i was like you know
what
gold why why gold
we won't go no no gold is good if
there's still confidence in our existing
social structure
yeah if there's actually going to be an
economy to speak up right bitcoin
and gold are valuable because of a
functioning economy as it stands today
let's say we enter uh i don't know you
know a walking dead apocalypse scenario
i do not believe that's going to happen
i know because
for the most part it hasn't i mean
countries have fallen but they still
have
don't economies but i thought you were
going in the zombie direction with them
for the most part it hasn't like
no no i mean like you know when
countries and or empires fall
yeah people still keep working and
eating and things carry on so so gold
makes a lot of sense well yeah we'll
look what happened when the ussr fell
right people still actually it was crazy
people just walked into factories took
them over
but that's why i was thinking like you
know what gun really is a good
investment
cars depreciate you know a good working
gun is going to go up in value
if you take good care of it it's a
decent weapon for sure yeah yeah yeah um
i mean even um a decent weapon i mean
if things get really bad any weapons a
good weapon you know any weapon's a
decent weapon
but i was i was genuinely thinking about
not the apocalypse i'm just like what
what's something you could buy for a
couple hundred bucks
and then in a few years it'll be it'll
go up in value and i'm like
guns not going to go down in value i
mean and
unless they ban all guns they won't do
joe biden now he wants to do a bunch of
nfa things so they want to they want to
make um
like uh so right now if you do a pistol
with a brace joe biden was saying it's a
that's a short barreled rifle yep
and i mean i've talked to a lot of gun
people were kind of like
the brace is supposed to go on your arm
but people just shoulder it which is
kind of like
a stock so they want to make that nfa
which means nfa means
it's national firearms act it means you
gotta it takes a year to get it's like
you gotta go get your fingerprints you
gotta go file paperwork you gotta pay
200 bucks per item
they want to make it more difficult in
that instance the guns actually go up in
value because they're harder to get
so it's a good investment but we got
some big gun news
so we were just talking about uh for
those that are just thinking we were
just talking about
all of the things that have happened
that have been very fortuitous for
this country if a war with china were to
happen notably
uh people were moving out of cities
decentralizing the economy
people are working remote so even when
they're outside of the city they don't
need to be in the same office
that's great if a bomb drops on new york
and everyone's working there in the same
building you could wipe out a whole oil
company
now you've got everybody not only have
they moved out of the city they're in
different parts of the country
and they don't even have to come into
the office that's really good for us
the other thing that happened that was
really good for us in the event of war
to break out people started buying
guns like crazy yeah record number of
guns and evil being sold
and as that saying goes i don't know if
it's true it would be impossible to
invade the united states because there's
a gun behind every blade of grass
now we have this big this big news from
a couple days ago california assault
weapons ban
disrespects freedom federal judge rights
i love that yeah he struck it down
good he said here's a quote he's a quote
let me read for more than three decades
this is crazy to me hold on just listen
for more than three decades california
has banned certain types of
semi-automatic rifles including ar the
area 15
under an assault weapons ban on friday a
federal judge threw out the ban
ruling that it violates the second
amendment to the united states to the
u.s constitution quote
the second amendment is about america's
freedom the freedom to protect oneself
family home and homeland judge roger
benitez wrote for the u.s district court
for the southern district of california
california's assault weapon ban
disrespects that freedom governor gavin
newsom called the decision a direct
threat to public safety you get the
point now this guy this judge
my understanding is that he was
appointed in 2003 by bush
i don't know if they mentioned that but
he's been here for a while
i'm just why right now are they saying
californians go buy your ar15s
how's that work can can any judge at any
time just look at a law and be like i
want to overthrow that i want to it's a
lawsuit
so someone sue saying banning the ar-15
violates the constitution
the judge said i agree now
for now there's there's going to be an
appeal so people probably shouldn't run
out and try and buy weapons
but i gotta say man when you think about
what's happening in this country
what were we just joking about china
beaching into you know beaching
california and running in
now californians can go by ar-15s the
second amendment
you know what what a well-regulated
militia be necessary for a free state
the right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be
infringed yeah i think well it's really
good news for a country
trying to secure a free state from a
foreign invasion should a war break out
that they're all armed to the teeth and
now in california after 32 years
a judge says you can go get ar-15s i
gotta say though this is uh
well there's assault saying uh best time
to plant a tree is 20 years ago second
best time is today
i don't exactly envy the people who are
just getting into firearm ownership now
i'm glad that i purchased my weapons and
my ammo before all of this stuff
but i'm glad they're doing it at this
point however it's gonna be really
really difficult for them to start
practicing with their weapons it's gonna
be really difficult to get range time in
ammo is so
so expensive i don't know how any of
those people would really become
proficient in time
for a war with china yeah unless of
course i mean i'm sure there's some
number of them who already owned guns
but didn't have an ar
yeah yeah we got like a laser bullet
targeting
uh device that you put you put in the
chamber and then it allows you to like
hit
a pad on the wall and it tells you how
accurate you are but it doesn't have
like the kick of the
of the ballistic it's just a way to
train without losing ammo so my first
thought is what are they going to try to
do to get this decision overturned
what do you think they're going to file
an appeal right i got
and that's it i mean it's going to go
through the courts it might go to the
supreme court i think it would be great
if it does
the assault weapons ban makes zero sense
you you will not find a human being
who knows about guns who will advocate
for those laws
it's true because even when i take like
the devil's advocate position
i'll be talking to a democrat or a lefty
and they're like we gotta have this
assault weapons ban
my first point is the one i bring up all
the time the one that affects me
personally
yes okay hold on this law so this law is
getting overturned and they're like this
is terrible news and i'm like actually
it's good news
in maryland for instance the m1a which
fires i believe it's 762 by 556. i'm
sorry
762 by 51. uh it's illegal
it's an assault weapon the scar 20s
which fires 308
totally legal they're almost identical
rounds there's a higher pressure in the
308
the law makes no sense the ar-15 that
shoots the 308
legal but the m1a is not it's like that
just makes noise
it's also like you have um the the mini
14
being classified or i'm sorry the ar-15
is classified as an assault rifle
and then the mini 14 or an assault
weapon i apologize and then the mini 14
is not
and so they fire the exact same round
both can have 30 round magazines
attached
they can fire the same round they do
they're usually chambered in five five
six right right right so that's
what's what's insane about a lot of
these arguments is that
they're like we're gonna ban assault
weapons what does that mean is it scary
or it's actually gone i need to double
check the mini 14 might usually be
chambered in two two three but
not that big well yeah but fires two two
three right right you need something
five six i'll do both
so whenever i bring up this argument uh
and i'm seeing i'm seeing it pop
up more and more maybe it's just because
i'm paying attention but a lot of people
are pointing out
uh the reason why we use five five six
they're small
they're really small yeah the reason we
use those is so that you can carry them
is so that in war people can carry lots
of them it's not a giant round by any
means could you imagine if people were
like going to war with like
sabo slugs like massive huge 12-gauge
they're like we're going to use the most
the biggest and most definitely no you
can't carry that much
and so when they talk about hunting it's
like you should go look at what they use
for hunting they got big
big weapons yeah we can't show anything
so we're not going to they are but we
actually have some on the table
the ar-15 is also an incredibly popular
hunting weapon too
i i don't want to forget that because
often they will say things like you
can't hunt with an ar-15 or you don't
need an ar-15 what would you use is
ridiculous yeah
i don't understand i guess i've got you
know i've got a
a i got a bunch of bolt action rifles um
for i you know i'm not like very well
trained or anything but it's
described to me that less moving parts
more accurate easier
versus air 15. it's got a lot of moving
parts so that affects accuracy but less
recoil
so i don't i don't you know i'm not
entirely uh
sure i understand what the argument is
from these people other than
is a gun scary exactly the ar looks
scary and also i mean
the ar has been used in many school
shootings and many public massacres but
people don't realize
it's not as if the maniacs who go do
these kinds of things are using the ar
because it's a particularly effective
weapon for doing that kind of thing in
fact
there was one article i read which was
basically hypothesizing that it's the
copycat effect
because the ar is not the largest i mean
the 556 is not the largest round you
could get you could probably
mean you someone could use an ak um and
that has a more powerful round in it
generally
uh and they always go with ars why why
because the media always reports that
the last guy used an error
it's the copycat effect i think uh so
the the ak uses 762 by 39
yeah i think those are those are smaller
than five five six
i'm pretty sure like shorter no they're
oh well they're bigger i mean i'm pretty
sure the round is bigger but i think
they're shorter i think i figured out
why they're
making uh ars assault rifles because the
letters are
make people think it stands for assault
rights people actually what it means
armalite rifle which is the company that
built the thing right right yeah
yeah so that's that's that one's really
obvious to a lot of people
like you dude it's not an assault rifle
and uh there's an assault rifle
an actual one uh on sale over at
gunbroker it's like 55 thousand dollars
how big is it it's a it's an m16
selective fire rifle so it's an actual
i think it's a pre-1986 when they like
shut down the production of these things
and uh it's really expensive it's really
really expensive if you want to buy
some of these nfa items takes a really
long time it's really hard to do and
that's
and that's why it's funny when the
democrats are like do not come and take
your guns i'm like bro mo
like a large portion of guns are already
banned yeah
already we're just gonna ban a couple
more and then we'll stop well so anyway
i'm gonna go back to my point uh i was
talking about this thing happening in
california which is very good news
we'll see what happens if it makes it to
the supreme if it escalates the federal
court gets appealed goes to the supreme
court we'll see what happens
but uh it's not all good news so i i can
mention hey how fortuitous for us
that you know in the event war with
china breaks out more people might have
ar-15s
and we do have some contradictory news
we have this from bearingarms.com
doj issues proposed rule on pistol
braces
model red flag red flag legislation they
say
two months ago joe biden announced his
first executive actions on gun control
promising that the doj and the atf would
issue proposed rules aim at cracking
down
on the proliferation of home built
firearms ar style pistols
that use stabilizing braces which biden
and other anti-gun advocates want to
declare as items subject to the national
firearms act
the doj's proposed rule on so-called
ghost guns was unveiled a few weeks ago
and today the doj released the agency's
proposed rule dealing with pistol braces
along with the model red flag
legislation the administration is hoping
states will adopt
in the coming months you can read the
full proposed rules here
we get the point so i'll break it down
and again far from being an expert on
this stuff
there are there are some there's things
called ar style pistols
and so you can get them in basically
like any round
they have this folding brace
on the back they call it a brace and
what you do is you you pull the velcro
and you can pull the bottom you can put
it over your arm
because a pistol you're supposed to fire
with one hand so the brace allows you to
be stable while you're firing
however these braces can be put up
against your shoulder
you can you can brace the firearm now
it's really interesting because
there's a bunch of people i've been
arranged where they're like never brace
the pistol because then you're like a
short belt rifle
and i'm like but you can have a brace
and put the brace up against your
shoulder and it's okay and like
people are doing this in magazine stuff
i'm like i'm genuinely confused by
like these rules yeah the rules are
really weird and confusing
my thing is right now you can go to a
store
and just walk in and be like i would
like to purchase that nine millimeter ar
style pistol with a brace
and they'll they'll do your background
check i think for a lot of first-time
buyers
you're going to get bad news they're
going to be like we'll see you in a week
come back and we'll let you know if
you've been approved for the weapon
so when i first started trying to buy
weapons it was like five days
every time i wanted to buy a gun i'd
wait because they're doing a background
check no matter where you go
and it's only recently i've been getting
researched which clears me in like 20
minutes
oh nice but it is a background check the
form goes they look at my name they look
at my social they do a background check
they say okay
and then i can i can purchase this
weapon you go to gun store and you can
just buy it
okay it'll it'll take you a little bit
of time if your first time if you're if
you've got
in some states if you have a concealed
carry you just walk in and buy it
if they make it an nfa item it'll take
you a year to get these things
and it'll be really interesting what
that means for people who already own
many of them because
then what you got to file a bunch of
paperwork what do you got to do right
so this is bad news for a lot of people
who have legal and
in my opinion firearms that are safer
absolutely safer
so you don't want to be and this is my
opinion okay i'm sure there's a lot of
experts a lot of opinions in the gun
world
i i was talking to some guy about home
defense because i tweeted about
shotgun versus ar-15 ar-15 for home
defense
and a lot of people are like shotgun is
a good weapon for home defense and a lot
of other people are like that's a
terrible weapon nobody uses it these are
for breaching doors and nothing else and
ar15 is better and i'm of the opinion
that air 15 is better for a variety of
reasons first and foremost it's a stupid
argument because the air 15 can be
a bunch of different things it can be an
air 15 pistol
with nine millimeter and you can use
like frangible or hollow point
i think that's better than uh a
shotgun but a lot of people don't
realize too so i got a remington
12-gauge
really long and i would told a bunch of
people like no no you got
that really long barrel in that in a
house you're not going to be able to do
anything with that
so then you think about these ar pistols
and
they're more it's going to be easier for
the average person to fire accurately
which is safer
as opposed to a handgun which i'm
terrible at handguns i i've been
improving
mind you but uh with the with you know
a rifle yeah it's tough points of
contact yeah
yeah yeah it's it's a lot easier i got a
really good advice last time went out to
range with with
improving my accuracy with a rifle
handguns i got a good advice but still
is difficult especially imagine this
you're in your house somebody breaks in
and you go for your handgun and and man
you better know what you're doing with
that thing and
but you got you have a rifle you're
better off now what's going to be better
for home defense
probably an ar style pistol with a brace
because
now you have it's not so long you're not
going to you know you're going to be
more accurate you're going to be using
you could potentially use a
less danger a less powerful round
because of these gun control laws
you you basically this is the craziest
thing i was talking to the guys at the
gun shop
they said in maryland it's got to be a
heavy barrel rifle and i'm like so you
can't have
a lighter easier lower recoil quieter
nope nope nope maryland banned all these
things
so now you quite literally have heavier
harder to use more dangerous weapons
which means
people who aren't specialists and
firearms which get something for home
defense
might miss that's the result of his gun
control laws not making anything safer
for anybody
making everything worse yeah no exactly
and there are some laws that have been
proposed i've heard
um from different people on the left to
restrict people
from purchasing more than like it
depends on the state but
they'll set a limit on the amount of
ammunition a person should be able to
purchase and they'll argue that this
would be an effective gun control
measure but the problem with that is
people just don't get to the range as
often and they don't get a chance to
practice with it
and then i believe it was in new jersey
where they
they um banned anything with a magazine
capacity greater than five
the momentum is in there yeah no i think
they're just ten okay
new york you you it's like you can have
at least you can have a capacity of ten
but it can only have six in it or
something like that
that's totally insane yeah i mean if
you're in an emergency situation if
someone is broken into your house
you're gonna be shaking when yeah well
you're gonna also like people don't
understand when they don't know about
guns they've never
fired one before that it's difficult to
hit a target on your first try and
especially if your adrenaline is pumping
because somebody has
burst through your front door and
they're trying to harm you and your
family you're probably going to miss
them
even if you do hit them it can't take
more than one hit to take a person down
it's true it's true but i do have some
good news none of that matters because
in most of these states that ban guns
you go to prison whether or not you hit
the person
it's like someone broke in your house
off the prison with you good news
yeah reminds me of uh this is like oh no
i just want to say i've had people
i have had people who i know ask me well
why would someone need
like a handgun with 15 or 16 rounds in
it it's like dude
because first of all if more than one
person breaks into your house and you
only have six rounds like
you're already done i'm sorry if you
don't know how to use a firearm very
well if you're not very well trained
i mean how often man i want to double
check this because i don't want
to get the statistic wrong but the
majority of the time when a police
officer is aiming at a target they miss
and they train more often than most
citizens do
so people barely train yeah that's also
true i i have a buddy who um
was in the military and he was a police
officer and he said that as a cop he
almost never trained which was
really unfortunate he was not a police
officer for very long he left
but yeah i don't know if if police
officers are not well trained enough to
hit targets then you expect civilians to
be able to do so with a limited amount
of ammunition in their magazine
my uh one of my favorite things you see
on twitter you'll see these arguments
that make literally no sense
and you know it's a meme because they
all repeat themselves clearly having
never fact checked it
and there's one going around where
they're like if you can't hit it in 10
rounds you shouldn't be shooting at it
yeah
and i'm like so you're saying i should
hit 30 to 50 feral hogs with just 10
bullets
also i get it 30 to 30 50 feral hogs is
a meme
but uh you just carry more magazines
it's the stupidest thing they're like
you should only have 10.
so there was a guy who actually there's
a sheriff he did a video where he was
like
you know using lower capacity magazines
but more of them
and the guys the times were negligible
in between
because when you have a handgun you just
press the release and then you put it in
and you start shooting again
and then when it comes to like an ar you
pull the release and you put in the
magazine you start shooting again
people like these arguments about
capacity size are
are empty platitudes from democrats who
are just trying to give something
to gun control people but i will say if
they keep gaining ground on that
eventually it'll be like bolt action or
nothing
yeah and you're like okay whatever
people will say things like
semi-automatics shouldn't be legal what
are you talking about
like technically revolvers they function
as semi-automatic
you pull the trigger it fires and then
it spins and you're ready to fire again
but you know this is the nature of
argument people who don't know
anything what are ar style pistols it's
like
it's basically the same function
mechanics of an ar-15 so is it like
armalite rifle
style is it or is it talking about the
ar-15 style
so uh an ar pistol or like an ar style
pistol i mean same thing
it's basically an air 15 but small and
then you're supposed to hold it with one
hand and shoot like a pistol
but they put braces on it that you can
put on your forearm to make it easier to
shoot
but people will you know put it like a
stock and you're not supposed to do that
but i guess that's the issue everybody
does it so that's why biden wants to
make it an nfa item
make it so that it qualifies as a short
barreled rifle
i think they need to rebrand the ar
because it sounds too much like assault
rifles
it's irrelevant i mean the ak functions
similarly
there's a bunch of different weapons you
can get that are semi-automatic rifles
that function and
it's just the ar is just a big it's a
good working mechanical device so
what does ak stand for you guys know off
top of your head that's probably a
russian something
yeah oh yeah there you go yeah well uh
let's uh how about we just do the
hardest of hard segways and jump to
something
totally unrelated
i think there is a conspiracy that the
nsa and the cia are all
making us more resilient in case there
is a war i think that there is that
conspiracy we're de they're
decentralizing everything
i don't know i have no proof they're
letting antifa run wild because they
want to stick them on another country
they're like we're going to say
because they're trying to wreak havoc
they want us to buy guns like crazy yeah
no
i hear you yeah millions upon millions
ammo shortages
yeah this is another thing man you got
to get just you know think so this is
someone like
the ammo pipeline well all this stuff is
going on there's massive government
contracts for ammo and ammo shortages
like it's just a lot of things where
it's like wow
all those things happening are really
good for us if a war breaks out
ammo shortages i wonder why the
government is buying so many bullets oh
they're
they're dispatching the air force across
the pacific to avoid a russian rocket
attack
and they're buying bombs for pacific
theater uh
really interesting that all of these
things are happening but i don't think
there's gonna be a war
even though we are in the fourth turning
and there's through city strip
and constant articles saying are we
going to war with china and now lab leak
hypothesis is becoming prominent
and accusations about china and are
getting really serious
maybe it's maybe maybe nothing happens
maybe this i don't know
maybe nothing happens but uh yeah man
it's uh it's
yeah it could be like a year and a half
long false flag
like the gulf of tonkin happened in a
day but this they're just like yeah the
antifa thing it's uh
they just want to get us ready i don't
know about that but i do know about this
oh from the daily caller twitter
suspends
former treasury official after he
compared brian stalter to the [ __ ] from
pulp fiction
this is uh not newsworthy but uh
considering you know for
those are just tuning in like or didn't
watch the last segments we were talking
very very
seriously about war and gun rights and i
was like and now we need to slam into a
brick wall of nonsense
to kind of calm down and have a good
laugh
at the expense of others yeah so
uh the reason i'm the reason i'm
starting with this and
we're going to be ragging on brian
selter it's not because
somebody compared him to the [ __ ] from
pulp fiction but more so because
he is being slammed quote this is how
state tv functions
glenn greenwald rips cnn's brian stelter
for fawning
over white house's gensake in one of the
most sycophantic interviews a state of a
state official you'll ever see
now this is funny we're going to read
the [ __ ] story but i want to just stress
the point that brian scott is the guy
who completely
who routinely ragged on fox as the state
propaganda
it's the propaganda arm of the state
this is what state tv looks like
and then give him the opportunity and he
just gives
i wouldn't even call it a softball
interview it was a wiffle ball interview
he was
he was lightly tossing wiffle balls to
gensaki who then hit him straight out of
the park
well here's a dab in the daily caller
they say internet accountability project
founder mike davis and former treasury
official will upton
were temporarily suspended from twitter
for comparing cnn anchor brian stelter
to the character [ __ ] from the movie
pulp fiction
twitter first suspended update on sunday
night after he made a post that mocked
the anchor
stelter has asked stelter had asked
press secretary gensecki
what she believed the media doesn't
accurately cover about the biden
administration
fun fact brian stelter is the
is the [ __ ] from pulp fiction hubtin's
initial tweet read
which was followed up by a jiff of the
character from 1989
from the 1994 film oh so they restored
it
wonderful upton was suspended shortly
after posing the tweet
but had his account unsuspended a few
hours later after successfully appealing
the suspension oh the federalist
reported
upton tweeted that he simply pointed out
that comparing a public figure to a
fictional movie character does not
violate the terms of service saying
correct
lol this tweet got me temporarily
suspended from twitter i appealed in one
i simply pointed out that comparing a
public figure to a fictional movie
character does not violate their terms
of service
shortly after upton was unsuspended
davis was then temporarily suspended
from twitter for defending upton's post
according to the federalist citing that
he had violated rules against
hateful conduct on the site you really
put
big tech critic w upton in a twitter
jail for comparing brian silver to the
[ __ ] and pulp fiction
i'd be very upset if i were the [ __ ] as
well
bravo good sir now let's talk about uh
not what we're getting you know i point
this out you know glenn greenwald
tears into cnn but take a look at what's
happening here you see the story
nigeria suspends twitter after twitter
suspends its president
i'm conflicted on this one take a look
at how
our media operates we got major breaking
news
censored in this country the hunter
biden story many people were polled
uh this was a recipe and paul many many
people it was the most people everyone
agrees now a lot of people are polled
and it turns out around six percent of
people said that it had been known about
hunter
biden they would not have supported joe
biden which would have been more than
enough for trump to
take many of the states he would have
needed to win but uh
twitter facebook youtube they collude
they ban people they do just enough to
make sure milk toast channels like this
one survive
but then get rid of anybody who's
posting anything too edgy or too
controversial and they suppress it and
they shut it down
nigeria struck back they blocked twitter
they say the uh the country announced
the move two days after the platform
temporarily froze the nigerian
president's official account on
wednesday
for allegedly violating its abusive
behavior policy quote the federal
government has suspended indefinitely
the operations
of the micro blogging and social
networking service twitter in nigeria a
news release
from the nigerian minister of
information and culture alhaji lai
mohammed's office stated
so you can see they announced it in a
friday state announcing the move
muhammad cited the persistent use of the
platform for activities
that are capable of undermining
nigeria's corporate existence
as a reason for the decision according
to the press release the nigerian
government did not provide more details
on how it will carry out the suspension
of tech giant's operations in the
country
or on the activities muhammad mentioned
in a statement an
aide at the ministry told reuters wait
and see how things will turn out
i don't know how i feel about this right
so again the gist of the story
twitter has suspended twitter uh
is suspended in nigeria after suspending
the president
i don't know i feel about that but i
kind of think it's an important move
um again i'm not sure i'd have to think
through it maybe have some arguments and
hear some some
some people what they think the
criticism i suppose is
a government shutting down social media
that sounds bad
what if people are rightly criticizing
that that leader is authoritarian or
what if he's a desperate what if they're
sharing real information trying to
challenge
what if it's like you criticize kamala
harris
and then she uses the the government to
shut down social media because
they don't like what's happening the
difference here though is that nigeria
blocked twitter because twitter was
interfering with its politics and that's
really really bad so it's kind of
inverted
if there's a politician saying and doing
nasty things and we use social media
call them out that's power to people
if twitter bans those people it's a
problem that's what twitter is doing
conservatives call out malfeasance from
democrats and get banned for doing so
we just read you criticize a cnn anchor
and they suspend you that's insane
but what happens when twitter is
interfering with your politics like they
were here
what happens then when the government
says we're not going to allow twitter to
operate because it's interfering in the
political system
this is different i don't know ian you
you actually have experience moderating
so i'm curious what you think
well with minds was where i moderated at
our terms of service were the us
constitution and
specifically connecticut law where the
corporation was formed so if someone
didn't violate the u.s constitution u.s
law
uh they wouldn't get banned off the site
um
what's your thoughts on this i mean look
i don't know what did he get banned for
he
i don't know he tweeted something
offensive so twitter suspends him if he
violates terms of service then the the
company has a right to ban him but
that legally but i mean it really speaks
it like how
how much more powerful these
corporations are than than national
governments you mean the other way
around i think the corporations has more
right power and influence than the
government if they want to not
necessarily they don't have a military
but they could definitely hire
you know blackwater or some sort of like
mercenary guard if they wanted twitter
could
they're not called it i think blackwater
changed their name now seven times yeah
yeah
they bad press i i don't know what do
you think mr sheamus
nigeria banned twitter because twitter
was interfering in their politics
i mean nigeria ah man there was a great
someone made a meme
um about this i don't think it was
nigeria was another country but
twitter was banned there and someone's
response was well you know what
nigeria acts as a private country
twitter can make their own
that's right so i i have to give credit
words too i won't try to pass it off as
my own joke but
yeah i'm not sure i guess i don't have
that strong of an opinion on this one
i think that nigeria can do what nigeria
wants to do
if they want to ban twitter that's what
if it's one that's i'm not gonna say
they've like violated some international
law so we
should go after them that as a nation
they don't have an obligation to allow
twitter to offer their service in their
country
what if donald trump was like my tweets
have been censored so we are formally
shutting down twitter yeah
would have been interesting yeah i don't
know i'm curious how that would have
played out if he can even have
accomplished something like that given
he was going to be out of office soon i
mean the biden administration would
surely overturn something like that
immediately
it is interesting because it's an
american company operating in america
the government doesn't have the power to
do so
but for nigeria it's a foreign
corporation operating in their borders
they very well could just be like so
twitter's learning that some countries
aren't going to put up with their
nonsense oh poor twitter i think this is
the same i feel so bad for that with the
florida law that they were talking about
desantis was going to pass that if they
you know ban if twitter banned some
people in florida but florida's like hey
you can't do that
the twitter would just get banned out of
florida as well like they just did out
of nigeria
interest blocked or blocked their own
activity out of florida all i know is
for a nation to say
that they don't want a foreign
corporation
to limit their leaders ability
to leaders abilities to communicate with
their citizens is not a bad thing that
just seems completely reasonable
thing is at what point is that
considered a foreign corporation anymore
like all corporations are foreign i
don't care where their headquarters is
right i mean they're they're hiding
money overseas they're putting their
headquarters in like ireland and other
countries to get away from taxes
maybe some of it's in nigeria you know
maybe they made a deal with one of those
princes
they're gonna start putting corporations
in space stations
oh we're not subject to anybody's laws
you can't do anything about it dude
there was this hilarious i was reading
about this um
there was this plan from some
libertarian i would imagine
to build this gigantic boat that would
just be in
international waters at all time making
this huge route around the world
and it was it was for the ultra wealthy
for them to run their businesses so that
they wouldn't have to pay an income tax
anywhere
and what you said just reminded me of
that like imagine at some point they're
going to have these space stations maybe
that's what elon's trying to do
he just wants to go tomorrow so you can
be like look i'm not in america i'm not
picking
there's just like one guy in a in a 10
by 10 space station
and it's just like it's their address is
one space way
to see and he lives there getting paid a
lot of money he can't spend
bezos is retiring as ceo and he's going
to be on the first mission he's retiring
blue origin yeah
and he's going to be on the first man
space mission on his new
rocket with his brother they're going to
be on like what do you mean on the first
day
they're going into space i think it's
blue origin is the name of his car oh
the first man they're planning in june i
think it is uh the first
manned mission into space and he's going
to be on the
on the rocket with his brother wow i'm
just waiting for something interesting
to happen
you know it's like every day i wake up
and look at the news and i'm like
it's kind of the same thing yeah it's
just boring inflation all it is is
reruns
yeah no you got to go inside if you want
to find the next step of
engagement in this reality i agree we
should go inside
but not with drugs breathing apparently
breathing can get you there
yeah you know uh certain types of type
of psychedelic trances and like
obviously diet but breathing if you do
different breathing exercises
that's where the excitement lies in
reality my friends you know we've been
in this period for
a couple decades where it's been
extremely routine
you know our conflicts have been it's
been so nice
it's been so good that the crisis we've
faced has been
rich people ripping off poor people yeah
it's by design man
they placated us they made ta marijuana
illegal they made lsd illegal they made
psilocybin illegal they made
empty illegal and they're trying to
suppress people they feed them all the
sugar and they keep them like
they have been doing that the rich
people have been taking advantage of the
masses
no hold on i think if they really wanted
to
lull people into asleep they'd allow
them to do the drugs no it's the other
way around
it's too dangerous for the status quo
for themselves then why do you think
they're legalizing them all then
it's just you can't fight the tide at
some point the people in the
democratization of power
overcomes tyranny at least that's what
it seems like happens
that's right you guys ever see that uh
vox article advocating for putting
lithium in the water
what yeah no i didn't let me see if i
can find it
you know mine lithium from water using
graphene filtration
did you know that you can mine lithium
out of water interesting
yeah i didn't know that that's bad yeah
so this is from
october 24th 2018 how our drinking water
could help prevent suicide
oh how could it how could that help oh
my god lithium is a potent psychiatric
drug one of the primary prescribed
medications for bipolar disorder but
it's also an element that occurs
naturally all over earth's crust
including in bodies of water
that means that small quantities of
lithium wind up the tap water you
consume every day
just how much is in the water varies
quite a bit from place to place
naturally the that made researchers
curious are placed with more lithium in
the water healthier mentally do places
with more lithium have less depression
or bipolar or most importantly
of all fewer suicides a 2014 review of
studies concluded the answer was yes
four or five studies reviewed found that
place with higher levels of trace
lithium had lower suicide rates and
nasser gaming the tough psychiatric
professor who co-authored that review
argues that the effects are large high
lithium areas he says have suicide rates
50 to 60
lower than those of of low lithium areas
quote in general in the united states
lithium levels are much
higher in the northeast and east coast
and very low in the mountain west
he told them in a new episode of the vox
podcast future perfect and suicide rates
tracked that exactly
much lower suicide rates in the
northeast and the highest
rates of suicide are in the mountain
west if you apply that 50-60 percent
reduction to the u.s where about 45 000
people died by suicide in 2016
you get a total number of lives saved
around 22 500 to 27 000 a year
that's likely too high since you can't
reduce suicide rates in places that are
already high lithium
gamey's own back of the envelope
calculation said we save
fifty fifteen thousand to twenty five
thousand well sheamus ian
if it saves one life then we have to do
it what we need
all in yeah let's uh so i think what vox
is saying is that if we put a
psychoactive drug in our water supply
people will be happier
um although if you go ahead and look at
the royal society of chemistry they just
released a paper that says continuous
electrical pumping membrane process for
sea water lithium mining
will eventually be pulling the lithium
out of the water and then utilizing it
that way either for batteries or for
feeling better
you know what i was i was i was i was
thinking a lot about this there's a meme
going around where it's a guy he's at a
psychiatrist's office
and he says every day i wake up with
existential dread and my life is
meaningless
and the doctor says best i can do is
give you pills that make you think
everything's okay
and i'm like that's dark man why do
people have no purpose
like why do they feel that dread why
don't i
experience that you know what i mean
like is it because i'm healthy it's
cause you're so handsome
part of it yeah sure you like has like
it has like compounding effects like
even in a few weeks even if everything
went to hell right now for you you'd
still feel good
in three weeks from the last six months
of activity let's talk about all of the
left's arguments on this one
first of all vox is saying put drugs in
the water i'm completely opposed to that
they argue that one of the things about
institutional racism
and generational poverty people from
poor areas they drink dirtier water
it affects their mental health they have
less less access to good schools all of
that stuff right
well i'm a shining example of all of
those things south side of chicago
public school uh you know low-income
family
homelessness i did all right i have
passion i have drive i don't wake up
feeling dread i wake up feeling great
i wake up i'm like gee i wonder what the
news a little boring sometimes like i
mentioned before like you read the news
you're like oh that again
but i'm always interested in seeing like
news stories ufos whatever
talking about this stuff it's either
that there's people that are activated
like there's a point zero zero zero zero
one percent of the population that's
so like able it's just like the
evolution
of a human that you're able to like
break through all the crap or that
there's a way to activate the human body
and become that
and for whatever reason you seem to have
mastered i'm chilling this
you know reality we're all kind of
chilling uh it was just funny your
description juxtaposed to ian's
and you're like i'm chilling but no i
mean i guess it's a complicated question
you have a lot to do um you seem to be
doing something that you really believe
is improving the world and that
takes up a good amount of your time
you're building something i think that's
a huge part of life and it's a huge part
of feeling happy
with yourself even purpose even before i
did any of this
i was not waking up experiencing
existential dread yeah that's a really
good question
so let me ask you did you have a goal
that you were working towards at that
time
before all this not really really so so
what were you doing every day
i mean before like literally right
before occupy wall street started i was
just skating and filming little skate
videos
and how long have you been doing that
for oh i just started a few months
before before that i was in california
just you know i was working at a
homeless shelter and some non-profits
and my apartment burned down and made
everything on the ground oh snap man
were you
you're down by 6th street where downtown
l.a is that where your home is
you're working which one were you at oh
i can't talk about it oh
yeah the plot dickens i guess my point
is so i don't know your whole life story
here
despite being a fellow illinois boys i'm
not trying to talk about me i'm trying
to talk about
other people and what's missing from
their lives oh sure that results in them
needing lithium in their drinking water
to feel better
i i think we've peaked as a society i
think this is it there's nothing to
aspire to
people don't want to have kids they
don't want to have families this means
that they don't really have a good view
of the future and you see this in
all of our policies we're never thinking
about what's coming down the road
you watch joe biden putting all of these
policies into effect he only cares about
the next four years eight years maybe
he's not even going to be around and i
think he knows that and i think that
there's just
no look toward the future at all we look
at people like angela merkel not having
kids
uh macron doesn't have any kids nobody
cares about what's gonna happen tomorrow
yeah we talk i can't remember if it was
on the after show or not but we had a
conversation about
how a lot of these people don't have
kids last time got a little bit with
keynes saying
it'll will be in the long run we'll all
be dead so who cares and he didn't have
any kids in that kind of thing
uh when you're asking the question about
why do we need lithium in the water
which again is something i'm also
completely against i think that's a very
strange opinion to have and also very
strange
opinion to have and admit to having as
this person uh
felt called to do in this article they
wrote
but some of it just breaks down and i
hate to overly pathologize but some of
it's just chemical
i mean there are some people who could
experience all the things you've
experienced or the things i've
experienced or any of us have and react
completely differently to them just
based on their genetics
but i think a lot of it is the way you
choose to react to things
i think kids i think not having kids
have been a big big
big big problem for millennials yeah you
know there was a super chat where they
were saying
that in response we did a story about
that valedictorian
or whatever where she was like you know
pro-choice or whatever and then someone
commented
that your dreams don't disappear when
you have kids in fact the moment they
had the kid it was like all of a sudden
all they could think about was the
future and what and
and the work and the passion the stakes
disappeared yeah it's almost like people
have no purpose
then they have kids and realize they
have a purpose they need the world to be
a better place for their children
and all of a sudden now they're
interested in doing you know and doing
things that matter
and a lot of young people don't have
that so they're extremely nihilistic and
self-interested
i think there might this might be a big
difference between the left and the
right
i wonder if you could actually track
this we
maybe we should commission a poll if you
align culturally
right or you know in the culture war do
you have children
on the left do you have children i'd be
willing to bet i could be wrong
that the left has a predisposition
towards less kids and their right as a
predispos
predisposition towards more kids that's
why leftist policy tends to be more
gimme gimme gimme
right-wing policy tends to be more
personal responsibility you've gotta
you know do hard work to succeed because
they want people to plant the tree whose
shade they know they will never sit
in the leftists are kind of like i don't
want to pay my loans back
that's like that's one of the biggest
issues for men on the left
i took out fifty thousand dollars i
spent it
you should pay for it that's not helping
anybody in the future it's making things
considerably worse yeah i mean i would
agree now to play devil's advocate on
that one
i think you can make an argument that
part of the reason they don't have kids
is because they have these massive loans
so they can't settle down and buy a home
and get married and do all the things
you would do before having a family
right but why do you go to college in
the first place i don't think the kind
of person who's planning to have a bunch
of kids is going to be somebody who says
okay let me just take on you know 80 000
100
000 worth of student loan this won't
affect my kids future lives at all
well i think a lot of people don't think
about that when they're 18. oh yeah it's
possible too
yeah but that's also a kind of a weird
problem because historically
if someone wasn't ready to have her take
care of children by the time they were
18 people sort of assumed there was
something wrong with them
i mean if let's look 100 years ago if an
18 year old man was not
capable of supporting a family people
would assume that there was a problem
with him
yeah yeah and so people were thinking
about these things at that age
historically and yep that you know why
shouldn't they have been by the time
you're 18
you are mature enough to have a family
despite what our modern society tells us
by the fact that we want to continually
extend
adolescence an 18 year old as an adult
maybe uh maybe liz right we we peaked
that's it no i'm gonna what do you mean
by me but peak
definitely not morally so well yes but
ian and i were talking about this the
other night we were like this is the
nicest the world has ever been
materially for sure yes yes we have
everything that we want you can
literally order pizza you can order uber
uber eats at two in the morning and get
literally whatever you want from
wherever it's open
it's it's insane no it's insane and it's
changed even from when i was a kid i
mean i'm 26 years old
but the the kind of comfort and
entertainment i have access to now
is completely different from when i was
a kid parallel like
i remember a time in my life where there
would be a movie or a tv
show that i wanted to watch and i just
like wouldn't be able to and nowadays
anyone can watch whatever they want
whenever they want they can order
whatever kind of food they want unless
they're just in the middle of nowhere
and don't have access
to the things people generally have in
society i mean
we are so comfortable and it's not doing
us any favors
we didn't have debit cards when i was a
kid we had only checks you had to take a
check to the bank
and they'd give you money or you have to
write a check and they'd have to check
with clear take like a week to clear or
whatever
that helps because i'll buy and sell and
my finances are probably
magnitudes better than they would have
been 30 years ago because of my access
to digital currency
do you remember those commercials when
debit cards became a thing
and it was like the visa check card
comes out and it was like people were
like dancing in line at the cafe and
just like swiping their card
and then like a guy walks up and he's
like fumbling with his wallet and
they're like no
no i i didn't realize like when i was a
kid didn't mean anything to me
i was like i don't do this by the time i
was an adult i had a debit card you use
it for everything yeah i got it when i
was 14. yeah
i think okay my thesis here what i was
gonna say is that everything is
convenient
and i don't think that the us can
recover and go forward until we give up
some of our desire for convenience 100 i
think that's
p i think it's pivotal i was about to
combine those two words and it was going
to be weird i'm glad i didn't
and i think that we're not ready to give
that up we want life to be easy we don't
see how it's crippling us we don't see
that it's making us
need things like lithium to even want to
get out of bed in the morning that's so
sad
yeah well i think there's also a lot of
truth in that people constantly seek
comfort instead of doing the right thing
or the things that will improve their
life because they've been accustomed to
having anything they want at a time they
want so
at some point you do become depressed
when that's the lifestyle uh that you've
been living
there's a point so there's a point uh to
borrow from someone else once again
actually my dad he made this this point
a while ago and speaking to a group of
people
he asked them like do you think you had
a better life than your parents did and
basically everyone raised their hands
and then he said do you think you're a
better person than your parents were
and basically no one raised their hands
and so he said well
maybe it's not such a bad thing that
hard times are coming maybe your kids
are going to be better people than you
that's what i'm saying i think that's
right how about we go to super chat
if you have not already smash that like
button
and go to timcast.com become a member um
i'm not entirely sure but we may have a
very very
dark and very serious bonus segment that
you're not going to want to oh yeah
i'm scared serious i don't even want to
be a part of it dangerous youtube
instagram like content like snapchat if
i even mention right now we might talk
about youtube would probably just ban us
instantly
before it even happened i've tweeted
about it but i'm not going to say more
than that because
it's like an instabat it's insta banter
i don't know what it is it's yeah it's
super creepy
let me check out tim so uh well we'll
just leave it there and uh but but smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and go to timcast.com become a member
the new website's gonna be coming up
very soon hopefully about a week or two
i'm really excited we've got the designs
and and we've got
you know the the mock-ups and stuff it
looks amazing
and the newsroom's coming along with it
we've got new people potentially you
know we're going to be hiring soon
we're looking for some field reporters
we're probably gonna have some staff
individuals who literally will just fly
around the country covering the stuff on
the ground
and uh there's a very serious issue with
the undercover and investigative
reporting we're gonna do with with
security and safety but
your membership is gonna be funding all
that so sincere thank you to everybody
let's read
some of these super chats all right
let's see
okay dynaside 13 says
based guatemalans if we say that here in
the u.s in protest we get called
insurrectionists while commies burn
cities down
yeah that's correct yep magic trillion
says tim you should fund your own
american version of shonen jump
you could call it beanie boy comics or
bbc for short hey yeah
bbc that's fantastic that is fantastic
they'll allow that yeah sure let's see
him runduff says you need to get tom
mcdonald on one of these one of these
days it would be big
no more snowflakes yes tom is like one
of the biggest most famous dudes ever
and we are like a medium-sized podcast
so it's very difficult to pull in the
big
you know the big the big names but um
tom's cool dude he's
always a lot he's always welcome he's
got open invite all right
caboose aka kyle says illinois boys
represented from zion illinois almost
wisconsin hey hey what up oh yeah baby
you're still in illinois boy i don't
care how close you are to wisconsin
that's right you're one of the illinois
boys
jay schwiffer says the 2.3 million
dollars in bitcoin paid to the colonial
pipeline hackers was seized by the u.s
according to cnbc and reuters
interesting little update keep it the
good work i wonder how they
seized a bitcoin address intriguing
uh-huh did you hear that ian yeah i
heard of it how did they seize a bitcoin
address
78 or not 88 percent of the money that
got paid to this
manual i don't know how are they getting
access to the
i mean obviously if you see an address
online if you don't the keys
how do you get it maybe the hackers
aren't storing their uh aren't securing
their computers very well and got hacked
wow i don't know maybe i'm surprised
they didn't just put it right to cold
storage
it's unlikely i mean i mean i guess it's
possible for but for someone to be able
to
hack the a pipeline like that and
not have their own computers protected
from happening this hacking's really
easy
really yeah okay they like they hire
someone to make some garbage
malware that's like does enough put on a
usb drive and throw it in front of a
building and then you're done
really yeah you don't even know how to
do any code it's not hard or send an
email you could embed stuff in
in in pdf files it's it's it's that easy
that's insane
yep all right c hennessy says tim look
up strong
town it's a project analysis on why
cities and towns are failing
their biggest findings are how suburbia
development doesn't pay a profitable or
break-even return on investment
wow i really thought about how there's
no industry in suburbs there's like very
little
they move it all out of the away like
jerseys
the new york industry rob from downtown
says have you seen the crowder h3 beef
h3 talked about you too interesting
what did they say i actually listened to
that today h3 had a very
underwhelming take on following what the
cdc says they basically just said oh you
know it's a bunch of doctors a bunch of
scientists they know what they're
talking about don't worry about anything
you just need to listen what they say
crowder took issue with this he's like
we do all our research we have like 150
sources
we do leftist sources we make sure that
what we're talking about is well
researched
and h3h3 really lives for the youtube
drama and they slapped back at him and i
didn't hear that you came up
so i'm really interested to see what
what happened i don't know about that
i've never even talked i don't even know
much about h3 at all yeah i don't know i
don't listen to them for a reason
ethan he's cool i watched some of their
stuff a while ago back when they were
doing skits
they used to be okay what's his wife
what's her name yeah now it's just like
a regular regular regular dudes talking
about stuff i guess
is that what it is yeah i don't know i
mean i i've seen a little bit of the
podcast but i mostly used to watch him
when he was doing commentary
i mean a there's a big difference
between like a comedic personality who's
not
involved in politics who forays into it
versus like a show that's like dedicated
to cultural politics and
political news so like you know maybe
maybe the real issue is
if if h3 exists for you know cultural
like mainstream pop stuff then drama is
really really good for them
i don't i don't i don't uh drag on a lot
of the stuff too much
like if something comes up and i comment
on it i'll
you know try and move on as quickly as
possible uh depending on the issues if
they're cultural or political like i
tweeted uh
an invite to andy no to come on the show
simply because this actually has serious
ramifications for cultural and political
issues
but when it comes to like talking about
movies or whatever i'll i'll make my
tweet about a movie and then like i'm
not going to keep talking i don't want
to
you know but but i think for like h3
that's
that's what they are they're a pop
culture like mainstream show very big
very successful
and so you know that's what they do it's
more like mtv-ish than say crowder which
is you know crowder is more daily
show-ish for sure
i don't i don't know why they would
bring me up yeah so i'm not sure either
but what i kind of came away with was
that um
crowder was basically like please don't
tell your audience not to do your own
research
like please don't tell people to just
blindly listen to one source or the
other he's like that's not a good policy
for the people who believe in you
and then crowder was like i'm done you
know i'm not going to debate you on this
this is we're done with this we're not
really
on an interview was he interviewing
steven or something no he was he was
just kind of
just like a back and forth between the
podcast
and and speaking of the comments that
you previously made what we have a
a super chat here matthew ratcamp says
tim i saw your video criticizing andy no
after he got attacked and i've got to
say i think the fact you had to go to
third world countries to find a
comparison it perfectly shows the point
that you seem to miss i i don't think i
missed it i will say however
i think perhaps i shouldn't have been so
crude i think that's the mistake i made
i stand by all of my opinions but when i
heard megan kelly read my tweet i was
like
yeah that was that was tactless that was
like it was after the show i was tired
and i was like i found out that you know
andy went on the ground and i was like
we're having a conversation about with a
lot of people
and then i was just like how dumb and
then i tweeted and i'm like probably
should have been a bit more tactful than
that but i stand by my opinions 100
percent
the right seems to to be so invested in
you know supportive personality that
they're cheering for
i'm speaking figuratively here people
got mad when i said this but a lot of
people agreed
a lot of people agreed everybody thinks
the right is cheering for sending one of
their generals down to confront
frontline infantry and lose
andy no is substantially more important
than to be there in the middle of a
crowd of random nobodies who will beat
him to death yes
that's that's the problem i took with
this why take that risk
and then you know it just became tribal
you know so so anyway i digress i don't
want to you know rehash too much but
andy's uh uh invited on the show i know
he wanted to come on before but
when he went to london we don't do uh
remote shows so i just tweeted him like
bro come on the show we'll pay for it
all
and we'll have a good professional
conversation because the the big
difference between
canceled culture on the left and
whatever is on the right though there
are similarities i've certainly
complained about
uh i think i'm more than willing to
invite anybody i disagree with to come
on the show
i'm willing to invite anybody to
disagree with under the show and have a
conversation
and i think most importantly like the
thing we disagree on is like
.01 of the entire
conversation so i think it's it's silly
for everyone to like
do whatever were you talking about you
and andy well i criticized him
like four or five times but it's a
tactic that i criticized but to me it's
such a mark of respect that you're like
you're a general
in this war like you don't send your
best general down to the front lines
like you care about what happens to him
he's important and meaningful like his
work
has been good but like most other
frontline reporters they retire at a
certain point when they're recognizable
andy said uh on megan kelly's show she
asked him she read my tweet that's why i
was like okay that tweet was a little
crass
i should not have tweeted it that way
okay that's that's fair i take i own
that one that was a mistake
um i should have criticized it and done
it in a better way uh that being said
she asked him at what point is like
enough enough you know you're very
famous
and andy said that you know basically
tim is sitting there
in luxury or i forgot which word he said
but without andy on the ground
we wouldn't know about a lot of these
things and i'm like
that's actually my point if andy
sacrifices himself by going into the
fray
and no one else is covering antifa's
extensively and knows who these people
are
we lose all of that coverage you don't
need to send a general
into antifa to get the news not this
general this time
there are time and a place where general
like julius caesar fought on the front
line with his men the entire time but
not by himself
no he had a group right right yeah right
so so that would be like
if andy went to an event and spoke to a
lawyer yeah that would be like that but
just like
it was a local protest in portland it
wasn't a major political user didn't go
undercover in enemy camps
yeah i just sent other soldiers to do
that yeah i think it was a bad move
you know and and it's interesting that
people are like
i'm seeing a lot of tweets at me where
they're saying oh look i remember tim
went to no go zones and i'm like yeah i
didn't go back
like i went to sweden once they weren't
looking for me they didn't know my name
they weren't trying to kill me i went to
thailand
after i go to these places i can't
return to them in fact like
uh i can't even go to china at this
point because of the things i've said
so you wouldn't send ai weiwei into
china
to go and report he is a prominent
activist critical of
of china i think he is right you
wouldn't you wouldn't send you know
these people into certain areas you have
to find a different journalist because
if the goal is to maximize
your output and to be successful you
can't send the best of the best
into the highest level of danger
if andy stops doing the work he's doing
then andy is correct
how would we know what was going on if
he puts himself at risk that if biden
was like i'm going on this next one
with the seal team put the steel team
people would be like leading from the
front gosh you got to do that cartoon of
that
no i know in some circles that's still
that from you thinking
but but anyway look look i think you
know
i think i think the point has been has
been beaten beaten to death
um you know so there's no reason it is
very important conversation
it is that's why i hope he comes on the
show soon to talk about the value of
of doing it on the ground by herself and
then getting popular and having to
you know re reconnoiter or recon how do
i describe it
recalibrate your your function the way
you approach the situation i went to
venezuela
and i got accused of being a spine was
forced to flee the country vice wanted
me to stay
they wanted me to stay to embrace the
controversy because would have been huge
news internationally an american
journalist
was you know forced to flee or like if i
remained i probably would have been
arrested and then it would have been
huge for advice where the state
department would get involved and i'm
like i'm leaving
like i know but like you know i even had
conversations with family they were like
you realize
if you get arrested and spend a year in
a venezuelan prison you will be the
biggest personality once you got out
that's why they're telling you to do it
and i'm like that's
not what my goal is my goal is not to to
be a symbol or a martyr or to make money
for anybody i wanted to come here and
interview people and see what's going on
i'm going to leave
so the point of that super chat was that
i do a third world countries yeah i went
to a lot of different countries a lot of
really dangerous countries
and there's a limit to what i can do to
be effective at a certain point you
become so famous you actually aren't
able to get information out without
impacting the circumstance yourself so
if you're if you're interested in
winning
um a tribal battle then
i mean this has been fantastic news
breaks and you know is attacked if
you're interested in winning on
principles you need to make sure you're
getting out you know sound and
and good information uh but that being
said look i i respect andy tremendously
i've known him for a long time
interviewed him on this channel way way
long time ago when we when when i was up
in portland
and i i completely agree that what he's
doing is so important that's why i'm mad
that he went down there on his own
like i like i wasn't coming i wasn't
doing what the left was doing and accuse
him of being
you know a a a grifter who's just trying
to
make money i was saying like you're
going to get yourself hurt you don't
have security
right we have so i'll say two more
things on this i don't want to keep
hashing it out like i'd love to have
this conversation with andy here
many conservatives when the news came
out
that it was potentially ending we didn't
know a handful of conservatives
and people on the right expressed to me
privately how
upset they would be if they found out
andy actually did that when the news
broke
silence why they're scared to speak out
against him for you know look what's
happened you know people are thumbs down
in my video they're insulting me on
twitter they're telling me i'm wrong
they're basically saying like oh yeah
i'm not going to follow you anymore all
that stuff
i'm not okay fine people are saying
tim's a grifter who's just trying to get
views and i'm like if that were the case
i wouldn't have criticized him why would
i do that
but there are a lot of conservatives who
i've spoken to who will not speak out
and i'm like that is the exact same
problem the left has they won't speak
out against what they think is wrong
because they're scared
i'm not but i i will i will i will
mention that i will also mention
there's a lot of journalists that we
have that that you know we know that do
on the ground work and do report on
antifa
and many have expressed privately that
they're going to be moving on or they're
they're talking they're they're planning
their big move from field reporting once
they become too famous
some of these people used to be on the
ground all the time and have now
launched podcasts because they are much
too famous
and you become a target and makes you
ineffective so
there we go all right wraith customs
firearms says
tim let everyone know the atf is trying
to make millions of us felons overnight
again
with new regs on braces to make them nfa
tweeted with how to comment on atf
2021 r-08 to stop them
because you have reach shout outs to
wraithcustomsfirearms.com
so i hope you guys have something on
your website that could help i could i
can direct them to
wraithcustomsfirearms.com
and definitely um we we need to get rid
of these these ridiculous broken gun
control laws they clearly haven't worked
no matter how many times they ban guns
they still
complain every day there's gun violence
clearly what they're doing isn't working
at a certain point you need to say hey
all those things you got over the past
80 years didn't work maybe we should
stop
no but if it's broken keep doing it i
suppose samuel eddy says i say we solve
this immigration issue once and for all
by reactivating the doctrine of manifest
destiny
you can't enter the us illegally from
the southern border if it's all american
soil
heck yeah oh my gosh yes conquest let's
go
all right uh spin it game says dear
fellow apes help
another gorilla rocket moon by backing
my board game cindershy around
kickstarter
ape strong together uh i bought more amz
nice
i said about that yeah i was like i had
lettuce hands the other day i was like i
saw it i was like
i woke up and i was like this is fun
it's funny no but you know i uh what's
what's coming
there's black widows coming out the
movie yeah and there's a couple other
movies and i was like i kind of want to
have some movie stuff because these are
big
like i think this will be good for their
earnings i don't know i'm not going to
pretend to be an expert on any of this
stuff
not giving anyone financial advice but i
actually really like the idea of movie
theaters
yeah and with it kind of ending you know
that's movie theaters will be opening
back up
it's like the only thing i really like
going out to do yes
yeah i hear you i always tell people
like what do we what do we do we put
food in our mouths
hey we want to go out what we're going
to imbibe something i want to put
something in my eyes
yeah yeah something different exactly go
to the theater sit there and put in my
eyes and ears uh
shout out to cindershire the game on uh
kickstarter is that okay there you go
oh here we go mike g says tim saw that
you fomo'ed back into amc
now that you're an ape again you must
change your twitter profile pic to a
green laser eyes according to agent 8
laws the prophecy must be fulfilled
yeah i didn't fomo i'm i'm not i'm not
confident in a lot of what people are
saying
i just it's not fear of missing out i
was just kind of like
i like the stock so it was going up you
sold did it go up more and you bought or
did it go back down and you bought
same yeah yeah yeah but but you know i i
cashed out some of the profits i don't
have as much as i did before
but uh i'm looking at all these
different stocks and i've got some like
ammo
companies i got a graphene company
definitely got a graphene company and
it's performed well yeah and then i
was like i don't even know what to get
so i was like amc's like
i shouldn't even sold it because i do
like it you know i and a lot of people
try to justify why it's not good and i'm
like dude
your theories about why the stock should
go up or down are irrelevant to me
like people are saying it's not worth it
because they don't make money i'm like
yeah people like it though
you know so it seems good to me i like
movies yeah i bought it
there you go here we go oh this is
interesting apparently uh ian is correct
armchair engineering says the restaurant
chain was originally named buffalo wild
wings and
weck the original bw3 restaurant was on
high street in columbus and allowed me
to formally apologize for making fun of
you you were correct the entire time
welcome seamus it is welcome hey if you
like that definitely check out quaker
steak and lube if you live in ohio or
pennsylvania it's on the border and it
is one of the best wing places in the
world
i hope they're still open i took it out
james ramirez says my wife and daughter
are not american citizens i have been
overseas for over nine years i was
waiting for trump
now i'm waiting for biden my family is
on my orders over
over a year i signed for this but it's
my family
where is the government for help yeah
oh man the b-dubs thing people are mad
at us
no i never thought the thing i'd have to
publicly apologize for was getting uh
this super chat tim and sheamus are the
stupidest i'm just gonna say this
the neo enigma says y'all are killing me
b-dubs was originally called buffalo
wild wings and weck founded in ohio
bw3's for short changed it to its
current name in 1998.
look at us right that was first idiots
really the people was i kent ohio
ian you need to be more confident all
right ian honestly let's go i should be
ian cast irl i've been
taking you there don't say that barbara
albright says hey tim i completely agree
with you on andy now also if you are
still hiring writers i would love to
join your crew which email
do i go to again jobs at timcast.com
yeah so um we've got one uh uh we may
have already found
one person so far who's gonna like
oversee a lot of it
we need a field reporter yeah we need uh
we need our own
riot crew oh yeah yeah for people to go
out and go undercover and do
investigative reporting
and uh man i'd love to have like 12
people just like
infiltrating all these different antifa
groups maybe uh
maybe maybe maybe we've been working on
something because i'm sick of tim
sending me yeah he's so good at it
though yeah i know honestly i blend in
with them really well
lots of undercover stuff we're looking
forward to doing but um probably not the
same kind of
stuff that o'keefe does you know ours is
going to be more
like reporting on the ground and we're
what we're going to end up doing is
having um a lot of freelancers
uh that's one way you get around uh uh
recognizability i suppose are notoriety
if you're a reporter they get too well
known
well you know you use a group of
different people you get some legit
conflict reporters to film
and then you take the footage back you
take their report and then you know
we're gonna do stuff like that so uh
it's all coming soon
all right preston thames has watched
your video on china u.s specific
escalation and my immediate
reaction was sick now we get to play
battlefield 4 irl in a few months
bf4 setting is cn ru versus u.s war
starting in late 2020
well then oh boy it's not a video game i
know you're just joking phil says what
ian expressed about what happened to
rome by immigration has happened here
many areas of the country are now just
colonies of foreign countries i was
thinking
it's happening so slow because we're in
it you know i mean you've
made this point a few times tim that
like things happen over decades like the
american revolution was like a 20-year
process but we just read about a history
book like it just happened one
one day and we're in the middle of this
crazy but i'm wondering if that thing is
happening here right now
um i haven't seen like a military
military takeover city but you see the
autonomous zones
yeah juan roda says i'm daca i know what
my parents did was wrong but i was
four when i came here i've been in this
country for 22 years i just want the
opportunity
do it right i love this country uh i'm
in favor of daca i'm in favor of
the people who are brought here as
children through you know
like not realizing what's going on and
now they're here and it's like all of a
sudden you realize you can't be a
citizen i'm i think that's a problem i
think we should provide some kind of uh
path of citizenship probably you know i
don't know something
however it has to come with a hard stop
it has to come with like a we do this
now we never do it again
the problem is i think that's where
we're already at we're already at the
point where we're like okay well we'll
naturalize these
these these these people who are not
citizens but we'll never do it again and
then they do it again and they do it
again and they do it again
it's tough i've been hearing stories
since i was like six in the 80s where
people come over and have their baby in
the united states just so the kid was a
citizen
and then the mom would leave yeah kid
would be a citizen
only tim says hey tim sheamus love you
guys's work i'm 20 and from idaho
i've been watching you guys since about
2016. i keep trying to explain to my
friends about how the left is breaking
the system
and can be racist but they refuse to
listen any advice i always ask them this
do you agree with dr king's dream
jamis can you ask the question again do
you agree with martin luther king jr's
dream
uh yes i would say so i do lydia i do i
do
ask them that that one day his four
little children will be judged
by the content of the character and the
color of their skin i love that quote
and when they say yes invariably ask
them how that dream is being served by
policies that are based on race
yep if they want affirmative action how
does that serve dr king's dream just
asking that
does that serve dr king's dream it's
part of me wonders if they're just going
to drop him all together soon oh
they've already been trying to they've
been arguing yeah so a lot of leftists
have been arguing that it was uh
he was pushing white supremacy and
colorblindness oh my goodness they're
like
i mentioned this during the riots in
ferguson and in baltimore
there were people saying that the they
were black activists black lives matter
saying segregation
the end of segregation was bad for them
because it forced them
into the white man system which they
were below because they didn't have the
same level of resources
and that when they were separate they
had their own family system their own
churches they had their own businesses
they're on wall street
so there's a lot of people and that's
one of the reasons they push this stuff
yeah i don't know what you do about it
sporkwich says never forget
quantity has equality all its own it was
russia's strategy in the cold war cheap
but plentiful
it is china's strategy as well it is the
communist strategy
because the individual doesn't matter to
them which reminds me about this um i
think it's i think it's called as a pa63
it's a i think it's hungarian
it's a soviet era uh rifle it's
chambered in uh nine millimeter makarov
and nobody ever wants to use it at the
range because it hurts to shoot
it bites it into your between your thumb
it hurts
and so nobody wants to use it i tried
wearing a glove
still hurts and so you know the modern
weapons we use you know the beretta the
glock or whatever they're comfortable
and i was like you think about it soviet
union they're like i don't care if it
hurts you
does it work all right then make it mass
produce it cheap
garbage hurts painful whatever and so
i am with my cartoons yeah yeah i don't
care if it hurts you we have to get them
done
wow look at this ben d says tim don't
look at the air force look at the navy
75 of our deployed nimitz-class aircraft
carriers
are in striking distance to china
hundreds of ships have moved into the
area of the last year
you all ready for this we got to keep
them somewhere it's going to get hot
that's right ian i like the optimism you
know what it just bothers me
where they want it it's the idea of a
war on two fronts
and i know that afghanistan is i mean
russia the big the wild card is russia
what how do the how did the russian
government how does
vladimir putin and his buddies think
about this are they do they want to
support china and chinese interests do
they want to support the united states
and
curb chinese you know militant
authoritarianism
because they're right there on the
border yeah i don't know well here we go
check this out
the one true madrigal says if taiwan
falls the chinese will claim the south
japanese islands korea and the straits
of malacca
because why would we stop them then
they'll control 25 percent of goods
transported globally and 90 percent of
crude oil
alistair vusin says taiwan is more of a
country than john cena as an actor
americans need to toughen up fast
because everyone knows the storm is
coming
maybe we need it so that we can straight
we can straighten out
strain out on american ideologues
oh man you do not want war dude no
or witch hunt on other americans richard
cook says
haha if you are depending on
californians to repel the chinese
you are more screwed than i thought
china won't invade they already own the
us
and fyi china would invade through south
america
or central america not the west coast
and then they'd come up over the land
i think they would do a series of
strategic cyber attacks on critical
infrastructure
maybe they would start with like our oil
production oh yeah so that way it would
cause economic catastrophe would reduce
our ability to produce and move
resources
they probably then start going after
food to create shortages which would
then cause
panic because when food prices get too
high people protest and rise i don't
think they want a war i just don't think
they want to work maybe economic
destabilization
but it's like no war i don't think
anybody wants that
right now even at lockheed doesn't want
a total war i agree with you
do you think though at a certain point
china does things where we're forced to
go to war like we can't just let them
keep doing it
kind of that encroachment on territory
thing is a tough one like like the nazis
took czechoslovakia they took poland and
you had at some point it was just like
what are they going to take next
and so it was like we had no choice
right yeah what do you think the chinese
are telling themselves right now
the americans are militant imperialisms
who are seizing more countries moving
more troops into syria
if we don't stop them surrounding us
with their aircraft carriers that's
right
we're under siege they're they're
probably looking
this is what people don't realize about
war so here's here's a way to describe
it to people imagine you're in the
middle of the woods you've got
you're in the middle of nowhere you have
no idea where you are you have a gun
you've got a small bag of food and a
little bit of water you're running out
you don't know where your next meal will
be finally as you're walking
off the distance you see somebody who
looks different
but they have they have a rifle as well
they have appears they have it appears a
small bag of food in some water
what do you do that they you both just
spot each other a couple hundred yards
off
what do you do signal
signal how would raise my hand in the
air what does that do if i see them go
for their gun i'm going to duck for
cover
and then you raise your hand and the
moment your hand goes up they reached
for their gun they put their hand on
their gun
um i think i would get down on get down
and then yell out call out to them
call don't speak english and they they
yell back kabbalah
blah blah blah so they so
this is the challenge right a lot of
people like to say things like oh i
would just
go and meet them and say hello how do
you know they're hostile
how do you know they won't be like i
can't afford to feed two people you're
not gonna help me i'm taking your stuff
dude did you guys watch the walking dead
that was my problem with rick grimes the
main character the walking dead
he had this shoot first policy spoiler
alert and like i kept wanting him to
like create a community and like lead
community but all he wanted he was so
afraid that they were
everyone's gonna be hostile yeah how
long did you watch for about three
seasons four seasons oh dude i'm such a
sucker i washed away dude i watched it
for like nine seasons
and maybe two of them were good once the
governor shows
so i feel like it jumped it lost the
plot after the governor yeah
all right we got uh this chat here
connor o'brien says tim you finally
mentioned a job that my experience is
relevant to
please check out the resume that i've
emailed a few times along with copious
updates on my firm crt stuff help me
help you
yeah do you want to write down that name
conor o'brien we'll we'll uh we'll take
a look it's a good irish name
i like the irish infiltration of uh yes
tim castillo
the irish infiltrator i'm irish
but it could have been the british
infiltration i know you said you're at
war with yourself constantly
irish and the british half but i'm glad
to see one side is winning that's all
connor oprah
puka says thank you tim for separating
trump supporters from these weak and
spineless republicans it's so annoying
when we get lumped in with them keep up
the good work
absolutely i also don't like it that the
left gets lumped in with
liberals because they are so different i
can agree with leftists on gun control
they're like karl marx says you know
under no pretext then i'm like i will
accept that argument
insofar as allows me to stay armed yeah
you know i don't agree bro you are
supporting the right thing for the wrong
reasons
that's right the right thing so if it
means i get to keep my guns
you know but yeah trump supporters were
the insurgents that came in and
and told the republicans shove off the
republicans hated it
oh man all right let's see we'll uh
try and raise money as we can but uh we
gotta
all right yep more people mentioning ian
was right kevin white says
it was bw3's buffalo wild wings began in
the midwest as buffalo wild wings and
whack
great restaurants i'm tired of being
shamed for getting this wrong
shame i still don't know i'm looking tim
and i are just getting grilled
nicodemus says you know that feeling you
get when you're about to jump off the
high board into a pool
that pit in your stomach as military i'm
getting that feeling i'm trained and
ready for war but man i pray it never
happens
i'm praying on that same prayer brother
i was talking about this earlier
um the u.s military wouldn't draft
anybody you know if it war broke out
they'd probably just go to young people
and say
we will cancel all of your student loan
debt yeah
yep for two years service and they're
going to be like
wow they're going to say we'll pay you
20 000 a year or you know 15 000 a year
for two years plus all your debts wiped
out you that means
look you're not going to be spending
that money right so you're going to get
out with like 20 grand
and you're going to do whatever you want
and then they're going to be like dude
awesome and they're going to like sign
the paperwork it's going to say like mos
like
you know combat infantry or something
and you know you used to go to college
to avoid the military
well and now people go into the military
to avoid student loans they want that gi
bill yeah i figured out what weck is
buffalo wild wings and weck beef on weck
is a popular sandwich in new york
consisting of roast beef on oh jew
soaked come
whack roll that's working wow look at
this sounds good
jurassic josh says the video game
channels i follow will not criticize
china
they talk about how winnie the pooh
references are banned in china but won't
say why
what do you say about this well that's
why we're in trouble man
because that ch the chinese communist
money is just too good
i know it's kind of paradoxical isn't it
but they've exploited us to the degree
where major institutions and businesses
are just like i don't want to offend
china because they pay my bills
there is a quote which is falsely
attributed to lenin though it is
relevant nonetheless
the capitalists will sell us the rope
with which we will hang them that is the
perfect description of the situation
with china right now
rex cars a lot says sorry to break the
news tim but buffalo wild wings is
anti-2a
i've heard they lobby for anti-two-way
but haven't been able to find any
articles sources for that though how do
you feel
kick off duty cops out too well that's
got to be proven because that's a very
serious allegation against a very
delicious
we have our we have our resident buffalo
wild wings expert right here well
speaking of wild wings
i have no idea let me just point
something out right
you can go get a big old greasy burger
and you can get it from b-dubs with
french fries and salt
or if you can get some nice wings
with some barbecue sauce and carrots on
the side
they do give you carrots sometimes
celery sticks that's right either or no
what
what's healthier french fries or carrots
and celery
carrots i'm sorry absolutely that's why
you go to b dubs
you get a nice chicken meal with
vegetables
i heard healthy 50 different types of
vegetables in a week those are the
people with the healthiest biomes in the
world and they've got
something in the world i can see it
that's including like seasonings herbs
gg player says wow is sheamus going to
be the new luke plants
lip's coming back yeah that's right he's
going to kick me out luke's going to
pick me up and throw him out of this
chair oh maybe we'll just have
you know we we are actually upgrading
the studio
we've just been waiting for this
computer because of the shortages
we're going to be moving the location of
the studio same building but uh
different area
we are um trying to get a completely
different setup
and it's going to require probably like
a full studio build which means the
cameras will probably mount in the you
know we're gonna do it right
i don't think anybody knows what this
room looks like it's like really
don't tell them yeah yeah amazing of it
it's it's like 25 000 square feet it's
one of the most amazing rooms i've ever
been in quite frankly
yes it's yeah i'm up here and you're
down there yeah you're down there
like differently yeah people don't
people don't realize like ian's actually
not even in the same room as us he's
completely different james is outside
that's where i have to stay
[Laughter]
yeah no i am i i am uh not here
permanently i'm visiting for
for a little while because uh i love
these people we're trying some things
out
well the goal is um i think we want like
maybe even like
eight possible seats or more so
we can have total just like battle
royale people yelling over each other
that'll be fun yeah yeah
to get a bunch of on-the-ground
reporters in in one at one time like
andy and
who else i mean we've had the riot squad
here at the same time that was really
stuff like that's awesome
all right jamie arizola says since we're
playing resume hookups will you please
give my
fifth or sixth entry a look yeah can you
write down that
jamie arzola can do all right let's see
we'll do uh we'll do a couple more here
how do i spell that uh a-r-z-o-l-a
perfect i was right
all right justin mcgilliverry says
go read war is a racket by major general
smedley d butler it's 25 pages the
audiobook is 45 minutes
the book tells how there were 21 000 new
millionaires made between 1914 and 1918
and some of the core sold for both sides
interesting
creepy man all right
rob santana says tim what do you make of
trump saying btc is a scam because it
undermines the dollar
isn't that the point decentralization
donald trump gave bitcoin probably one
of the best endorsements in my opinion
and i'm a big proponent of bitcoin so i
own i own a fair amount
he said it you know it competes with the
dollar and we want the dollar to be the
currency around the world and i was like
wow what did trump just say bitcoin is
hard competition for the us dollar
yeah and is undermining its position as
the global currency
now that's the best endorsement i've
heard for bitcoin because like even if
it never overtakes the dollar
you just straight up said it is unequal
footing after 10 years
so i i bought more bitcoin when trump
said that oh yeah yeah it's like what
and
and so it's like there's a dip right now
and i'm like
you know i got to be honest i i don't
care it it could go down to a dollar i
would just buy as much as i could oh my
gosh yeah
yep yeah and and and other currencies
too you know
oh yeah it did depart it's down to 33
now yep that's an opportunity in my
opinion that's
i'm not telling anybody what to do not
financial advice no i bought some though
all right my friends if you haven't
already smash that like button subscribe
to this channel
share the url to this show and leave us
a good review on itunes or wherever you
may be listening to it
you can follow us on facebook and
instagram at tim cast irl
and the reason we're you know adamant or
i should say adam but the reason we're
like we're going to do a facebook
is that it's just where a lot of people
are and we're hoping that a lot more
shares will drive people to the website
timcast.com
because we're launching a newsroom very
very soon i mean i think our timeline is
supposed to be like a week or two
i know i said that last time like we're
getting a new website it was like a
month after i said it was supposed to
come out
but uh one of the issues gonna hold us
back is we gotta definitely hire these
reporters
and they've gotta be here in time for
the launch that we have the newsroom up
and running
otherwise it'll be like a very limited
aggregator for the time being but uh
it's it's all thanks to your membership
and i'll just i'll stress
when we launched timcast.com we did not
expect this many people to sign up so
quickly
and all of a sudden i was like staring
at a bank account where i'm like i think
we're gonna start a newsroom and like
hire like crazy and build a crazy
website and like take this
you know we've got the opportunity to do
so we don't need investors anymore
so people are are invested and i'm like
let's make it happen
it's tough though man my brain is like
on fire you know working every day
i think there's a lot of people who
don't understand youtube is not the
end-all be-all
there's a lot of youtubers who like
dedicate all their time and energy to
youtube that's a mistake i made very
early on
should have started a website a year ago
or a year and a half ago
so i was just like youtube youtube view
subscribers youtube youtube youtube and
i'm like that was a big mistake
so like a subscription model no i just
like a company that's bigger that's
better but you would
have worked the subscription website a
year ago going back
not necessarily i'm just saying like not
focusing everything on youtube
youtube is not the end all be all and
too many people are it used to bother me
people like i'm a youtuber because
in 2006 seven i'm like no you're an
internet video maker
you're using youtube as your platform
right now but it's the video that's the
power
not the it doesn't matter what site
right james o'keefe was kicked off
twitter
and he's still putting out videos that
are getting massive playing getting
millions of views because like
like he says james says content is king
but anyway um so subscribe and go to
timcast.com
and just uh right now it's basically
like an aggregator for all of my content
and the tim castle clips and the vlog
clips and then we've got the members
only section
but coming soon we're going to have
we're going to be commissioning op-eds
from other writers
we're going to be having like a literal
news editor who's going to be you know
we're going to have articles op-eds
opinions analysis
it's going to be your lovable centrist
milk toast outlet
and we're going to take fact checking
very seriously and so we're looking
we're looking to hire a a hardcore
newsroom journalist whose job is going
to be
to do fact checking and investigation
and they're going to be writing most of
the day
we're looking to commission people to go
on the ground and do field reporting
we're looking for a dedicated fact
checker who's going to be in a different
building who will then look over the
pieces and do independent fact checks
so it'll be double fact checked from a
fact checker factoring the news and then
getting fact checked themselves
and then we're going to have many docs
short films um all that stuff
and uh we're looking to also have
freelance writers from across the
country writing different stories and
taking submissions so we'll have a news
editor for that so a lot of jobs that we
gotta hire for we gotta hire for now
and all of those jobs will be in the
building
so you'll you will have to be in the uh
eastern
west virginia maryland area just so you
know but uh feel free to submit
and uh yeah so uh sheamus i hear you got
the
you got a a youtube channel i do yeah
youtube.com
freedomtunes just check my channel out
you can just google freedom tunes
and um we're at uh 643
000. it'd be awesome to get up to 650
000 if you guys want to go over there
and subscribe we're also
uh planning on releasing a video
tomorrow and then another video thursday
i'm really excited the one that we have
slated for tomorrow is
one which tim and i voiced
yesterday or no last week i think friday
and we were
crying laughing i heard you guys through
the floor yeah
did you yeah yeah so ian can verify
we're crying laughing youtube.com
freedomtunes sheamus do you have a merch
site i also have freedomtunesmarch.com
if you want to check that out
yeah freedom tunes merch just go there
buy a t-shirt tomorrow would like
tomorrow it's not financial advice can
we announce what you're putting out
tomorrow
or no keep it a secret how much i'm
trying to figure out i just say that
i'm too late i said it a minute no yeah
i said so oh yeah we were recording yeah
tim is in it tim is in it
it was one of the funniest like half an
hour or vo sessions
so yeah we were so hard to record
because we were laughing so much we were
crying and then we like improved
an idea for a completely different video
afterwards so we're gonna have that's
the best stop
yeah exactly so we're gonna have another
video we've collaborated can i give him
a hint
yes of course droplet
oh my gosh oh i'm so pumped yeah so
go over to freedom tunes and subscribe
please subscribe
people become graphene they're like
what's happened to me special shout out
to
to cast castle the new the newest
addition to the tim cast media network
because last week
i um made some bread made some cricket
bread
it's actually up now at youtube.com cast
castle the newest episode and you can
see i accidentally used
avocado oil when i think i meant to use
olive oil and i was using
half cup of the half cup of flour not a
full cup people were like he's using too
much flour
it was half a cup of flour but if you
want to see how that's done done by
by eyeball go check it out yeah he's
he's actually quite good at baking bread
he's been working on it since we were in
new jersey he's quite
talented i'd want to say before i go
that i do have a very positive spin on
all this nonsense and what sheamus was
talking about how
hard times are in fact going to create
strong men i think that if you're
planning on having kids in the near
future you should be
preparing them for the future it's a
little bit like when you get to the top
of the roller coaster and you know the
drop is coming and you just got to kind
of grit your teeth because there's
nothing you can do about
it you uh you bought the ticket you're
on the ride
and uh your kids are going to be strong
people you better make them into good
ones
anyway you can follow me at
sourpatchlids on twitter if you'd like
to for more nuggets like that
that's right those out good stuff we are
going to have a bonus segment which
would get us banned from youtube
instantly
if i even mention what we're going to be
talking about i'm not even kidding
because it's it's seriously dark stuff
i don't know what it is yet so but it's
but it's affecting our society in a very
very awful way and so
we'll bring it up and go to timcast.com
become a member and we'll see you all
there
bye guys
you